Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim.
Pridlaff und ich begrüße alle zur 125.
Ausgabe von UKW, in der es wenig überraschend heute wieder um die Ukraine geht.
Allerdings heute mal nicht mit Pavel, sondern es gibt die Gelegenheit mal wieder
einen Bericht von vor Ort einzuholen und dazu begrüße ich den Enno Lenze. Hallo.
Hallo.
Genau, Enno. Du warst nämlich wieder in der Ukraine und das relativ nah auch am Geschehen.
Und die Gelegenheit wollte ich mal nutzen, hier nochmal so eine andere Perspektive reinzubringen.
Ich hatte ja mit Pavel in der letzten Sendung oder beziehungsweise in den letzten
Sendungen, wie wir es halt immer machen, reden wir halt sehr viel über die gesamtmilitärische
Situation, Die gesamtpolitische Situation, insbesondere die internationale Situation,
soweit wir sie eben beobachten können.
Aber es ist immer sehr schwierig, einen Einblick einerseits in die Diskussion
in der Ukraine selber zu bekommen, einerseits, weil da relativ wenig darüber
berichtet wird, andererseits, weil man da natürlich Sprachprobleme hat und so weiter. Weiter.
Genau, aber wer hier fleißig zugehört hat, weiß ja, du bist ja mehr oder weniger regelmäßig vor Ort.
Das war jetzt allerdings ein nicht so angekündigter Besuch eigentlich,
wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Wolltest du im Dezember das nächste Mal wieder
hin? Was ist passiert? Genau.
Was passiert ist, ist, dass ein Bekannter sagte, ich fahre morgen los.
Willst du mit? Und dann habe ich gedacht, nee, ja, ich müsste so 10,
12 Tage haben, bis ich wieder hier sein muss. Es hat sich dann kurzfristig auch anders ergeben.
Ich dachte ja, man ist ja neugierig. Also wenn sich die Gelegenheit ergibt,
jetzt mit jemandem hinzufahren und auch wieder andere Leute kennenzulernen oder
so eine andere Ecke von Menschen, die ich nicht jeden Tag dort sehe, dann immer.
Und dann sind wir halt am nächsten Tag losgefahren.
Okay. Und was war jetzt anders als sonst?
In erster Linie, dass das ein anderer Journalist einfach ist,
also Peter Patrick Enzle und der kennt einfach andere Menschen, kann man sagen.
Also ganz trivial, aber eine Menge verschiedener Menschen kennenlernen vor Ort
ist halt immer gut, um seinen Blick weiterzuhalten.
Weil am Ende treffe ich ja, sagen wir mal, 70 Prozent immer die gleichen Leute
oder die Freunde von Freunden und so.
Und deswegen denke ich, ist immer gut, irgendwie sich auch mal andere Leute
dran zu klemmen, um eine andere Ecke zu sehen oder eine andere Art Menschen oder sowas.
Es gibt halt viele Millionen Menschen dort und immer im eigenen Saft schmoren
ist halt auf Dauer nicht gut für die Meinungsbildung.
Ja, genau. Vielleicht wer jetzt noch nicht so ein klares Bild davon hat,
was du so normalerweise treibst, also wir haben ja jetzt hier glaube ich zweimal schon zur Ukraine.
Also mindestens zweimal ja.
Nach Butscher direkt, das war das erste Mal und dann nochmal im.
Februar diesen Jahres, kurz bevor wir dann beide auch gemeinsam vor Ort waren.
Genau. Und du bist sozusagen so ein bisschen Journalist bei Accident,
bist in den letzten 10, 12 Jahren da in diese Rolle reingekommen und nutzt jetzt
die Gelegenheit sozusagen immer wieder über deine Kontakte vor Ort einfach auf
Tuchfühlung zu gehen mit dem Geschehen.
Und sowas dann jetzt wieder.
Und wo genau hat dich jetzt der Weg hingeführt?
Ja, vor allem in Pokrosk, also im Donbass, einem kleinen Ort,
um den zurzeit besonders stark gekämpft wird.
Und gewohnt habe ich sozusagen in Kramatorsk, das ist so der ein bisschen größere
Ort, der auch grundsätzlich sogar einen Flughafen hätte, der aber nicht benutzt wird.
Und so ein bisschen östlich von Liman in so verschiedenen oder östlich von Isium
in so Dörfern war ich noch ein bisschen unterwegs einen Tag lang.
Das war so der Hauptpunkt und dann eben so die Klassiker Charkiv,
Kiew, Lviv, was man halt so auf dem Weg mitnimmt.
Genau, weil du dann mit dem Auto hingefahren bist und mankelst direkter Flugverbindung,
dauert das natürlich dann auch eine Weile.
Genau, bequem 25 Stunden im Auto, also natürlich auf mehrere Tage verteilt,
aber man genießt es nicht.
Ja, verstehe.
Vielleicht bevor wir jetzt auf die konkrete Situation vor Ort eingehen,
also was ich mit Pavel jetzt nie so richtig habe gut einfangen können, ist,
wie schon erwähnt, einerseits so ein bisschen die Stimmung vor Ort,
Aber was wir auch ein bisschen rausgelassen haben ist, wie sehr eigentlich der
Krieg konkret das Land derzeit trifft.
Also wie hart ist es eigentlich wirklich?
Man kann immer viel über Angriffe und Rückzüge und so weiter,
also an das Frontgeschehen reden und das ist natürlich auch irgendwie immer
das, was einen so von oben betrachtet immer am meisten interessiert.
Aber wenn man so durch die Tagesnews durchblättert und sich die ganzen Timelines
durchliest, dann ist es halt auf der einen Seite, ja klar,
Erfolge, hier wieder zehn Panzer auf einmal gekillt, aber auch Angriffe auf
die Infrastruktur, Angriffe auf Häuser in ukrainischen Städten,
Angriffe auf die Infrastruktur.
Was ist so dein Eindruck, wie sehr das Land derzeit eigentlich unter diesem Krieg leidet?
Sehr, sehr stark. Ich glaube, das Hauptproblem ist auch, jedes Teil einzeln
genommen, also mal ein Stromausfall, mal kaltes Wasser, mal ein Alarm,
bei dem nichts passiert.
Das ist alles halbwegs trivial, aber über Jahre das quasi als Alltag zu haben,
also in Phasen. Es gab auch Phasen in Kiew, da gab es eine Woche kein Luftalarm
und dann wieder fünfmal am Tag.
Aber genau dieses Unbeständige und das Nichtwissen und dauernd von einem Problem
ins andere rüpfen, das zermürbt die Leute einfach.
Also man merkt nicht, dass sie sagen, heute Morgen der eine Kaffee,
den ich nicht kochen konnte, ist das Problem oder jetzt dieser Alarm,
wo wir sitzen, sondern halt dieses, man schläft halt auf Dauer ziemlich schlecht.
Zum Beispiel als ich jetzt in Kiew nur eine Nacht quasi auf der Durchreise war,
hatten wir trotzdem Alarm und über dem Haus ist irgendwas abgeschossen worden.
Wacht man halt auf, alles scheppert, die Alarmanlagen gehen an und wenn man
das dann, also man kann sich ja vorstellen,
wenn man sagen wir drei Wochen vorm Monat nicht durchschläft,
sondern zwei, dreimal die Nacht aufwacht, dann ist man schon mal platt und wenn
man dann morgens eine kalte Dusche nur hat.
Und das geht halt auch beim besten Gemüt auf die Nerven irgendwann.
Und das merkt man, wieso zermürben und ermüden bei allem, was die Leute positiv sehen wollen.
Und auch, dass es zusammenschweißt und dass sie sagen, okay,
wir ziehen das jetzt durch, bis wir die Russen vertrieben haben.
Aber halt diese allgemeine Erschöpfung.
Also wie bei den Nerds so ein bisschen Vierter Kongresstag. Also man mag es
schon da zu sein, aber es schlaucht irgendwann ungemein.
Und wenn man das jetzt noch, sagen wir mal, unfreiwillig hat und über ein Jahr,
kann man sich ja so vorstellen, der Tag wird nicht besser. Und das ist so,
was man, sagen wir mal, ganz allgemein im Alltag mitbekommt.
So dieses Schlappsein, Müdesein und auch so dieses so, wie lang geht denn das
noch und wie nervig ist denn das?
Und daraus resultierend dann auch immer wieder, dass es heißt,
hey, ihr habt doch noch eine Menge Patriot, stehen ja gut bei euch in der Garage.
Es ist ja schön, dass ihr die in einem NATO geschützten Land in der Garage stehen
habt. Vielleicht könnte man die mal rüberschicken.
Und ja, also so könnte man es grob zusammenfassen, so diese Abnutzung von normalen Leuten im Alltag.
Ja und dazu dürfte ja noch dazukommen, dass wahrscheinlich jeder irgendjemanden
kennt, der in diesem Krieg schon zu Schaden gekommen ist, getötet worden ist,
verletzt worden ist etc.
Der Stress auch für die Jugend, sozusagen die Angst selber im Kriegseinsatz
in irgendeiner Form zu Schaden zu kommen.
Natürlich auch die Angst der Familien darum.
Ich glaube es ist ein bisschen schwierig sich das so vorzustellen.
Und ich glaube, gerade wenn ich so auf die Debatte auch in Deutschland schaue
und die Wahlergebnisse der letzten Wochen,
dann ist das schon eine Wohlstandsverwahrlosung, die ich da so sehe.
Weil wir einfach dieses Gefühl einer solchen unmittelbaren Bedrohung einfach
seit so vielen Generationen nicht mehr haben,
die dann auch vor allem durch einen extremen Wohlstand ersetzt wurde,
dass wir uns einfach in diese Situation gar nicht mehr reinversetzen können.
Ja, genau. Der letzte Punkt ist, glaube ich, das Entscheidende.
Die Bedrohung, die Leute erfassen gar nicht, welche Bedrohung oder vor was.
Also ich merke es ja immer wieder, die Leute leben hier so auf ihrer Polly Pocket
Insel, dass die sagen, boah, das könnte ja so schlimm sein, dass der Strom mal
ausfällt. Er sagt, nee, nee, wenn so ein Krieg losgeht, dann ist mal ein Stromausfall
echt deine geringste Sorge.
Da gewöhnt man sich dran, da nimmt man eine Powerbank mit. Aber so das merke
ich, man kann den Leuten das nicht mal vermitteln.
Also so das ist ja wirklich jetzt zwei, drei Generationen weg das Problem.
Das hat in deren Leben nie stattgefunden, nichts annähernd in der Art.
Und das finde ich auch schwierig, weil also weder will man denen ja sagen,
du bist blöd, noch will man sagen, hier, guck mal, Schockbilder,
eine zerfetzte Leiche oder so, das taugt ja auch alles nix.
Aber ich habe das immer wieder auch auf verschiedene Art versucht oder darüber
nachgedacht, aber wie will man jemandem sowas vermitteln, der, also.
Wo man nicht mal den Ansatz hat, sozusagen auf einer, weiß nicht,
auf einer empathischen oder intellektuellen Ebene oder so zu erklären,
was das Problem ist, weil es nicht mal in der Fantasie von deren Lebensrealität vorkommt.
Und das finde ich dadurch so schwierig, weil wenn die Leute es verstehen würden,
dann gäbe es zwar immer noch ein paar, die sagen, Russland ist gut oder irgendwas,
aber die ganze Diskussion wäre eine andere.
Aber es ist halt, also diese Gesellschaft, Oder sagen wir mal,
hier gilt es als unglaublich schlimm, wenn man auf Hartz IV fällt,
wo man sagt, ja, das ist auch nicht schön und das ist auch ein schlechtes Leben.
Aber verglichen mit dem Rest der Welt ist das immer noch ein Luxusleben,
also mit einem Großteil der Welt.
Und da merkt man so, bei Hartz IV endet für viele in Deutschland die Vorstellung,
was ein schlechtes Leben ist und schon obdachloser ist, obwohl es die hier gibt,
für viele so nicht fassbar, was das heißt oder so.
Sagt, ja, und jetzt nochmal tiefer.
Und das, ja, das kriegt man gar nicht vermittelt.
Und was du auch sagtest mit, dass jeder da mal schon jemanden verloren hat und
so, was ich halt mitbekomme von Freunden aus der Ukraine, die in Deutschland leben,
dass die auch so hin- und hergerissen sind, die sagen, hey, bekannte Freunde,
Verwandte oder so von uns müssen jetzt dienen und ich will denen helfen.
Und auf der anderen Seite wollen sie den Kontakt zu denen den aber gar nicht
so vertiefen zu der Zeit, weil die sagen, was ist, wenn ich jetzt anfange zu
helfen und weiß, ein richtig engen Kontakt mit dem Aufbau und dann stirbt der.
Also so, dann willst du es vielleicht gar nicht wissen und wäre bequemer,
also wenn es jetzt ein Schulfreund ist, wo man über zwei Ecken mitbekommen hat,
dass der jetzt bei der Armee ist, wenn du einfach nicht nachfragst und der stirbt,
kriegst du es gar nicht mit.
Und wenn du da richtig reingehst ins Thema und dann eine viel tiefere emotionale
Bindung hast und die Person stirbt, dann trifft Dich das halt auch ziemlich,
auch wenn du in Deutschland sitzt.
Und auch solche Sachen, also so Abwägungen. Man sagt, ich hätte nicht mal einen
Tipp, was du machen sollst, weil es musst du halt persönlich entscheiden.
Aber ja, auch so Entscheidungen, über die man vorhin nachgedacht hat.
Man sagt, klar, da hilft man ja.
Und dann sagt man ja, warte mal, das hat auch Folgen für dich.
Auch wenn es eine sehr bequeme Folge ist, dass man nur eine Nachricht bekommt,
es ist jemand verstorben. Den trifft es härter.
Ja, aber das sind auch ganz viele, also so tausend Details,
die dann auf einmal zusammenkommen, die diese ganze Gesellschaft da so hin und
her schieben und reiben und manche kommen gut mit klar und blühen quasi auf
und sagen, okay, da muss ich jetzt umso mehr helfen, dass das weniger passiert, andere halt nicht.
Ähm, ja, das ist, ähm, also zum einen ist es gleich sehr schwer zu beschreiben
und zum anderen auch, selbst wenn ich da immer wieder bin und mit Leuten spreche,
dann bin ich ja immer noch jemand,
der es besucht und der seinen deutschen Pass hat und der innerhalb von einem Tag in Sicherheit ist.
Und ich kann auch an der Grenze an allen vorbeifahren und sagen,
hallo EU-Bürger, ich darf bitte einmal vor und,
das ist halt auch so eine Situation, also wo ich immer denke,
so wie viele Leute hier nicht mal verstehen, was ich weiß,
verstehe ich wahrscheinlich auch nur einen Bruchteil von dem,
wie es den Ukrainern natürlich geht, die da noch mal anders drin sind und ich
hänge so in der Mitte und da merke ich schon, das ist schon ganz schön schwierig
oder auch, wenn ich hier wiederkomme und sage, geil, eine Nacht durchpennen,
So, wie geil ist das denn?
Und wenn ich Und warme Dusche. Ja, genau, warme Dusche. Also auf dem Rückweg
war es so, ich habe in Warschau Pause gemacht.
Ich bin von Kiew losgefahren und dann bis Warschau. Und dann war ich so müde,
dass ich halt irgendwo ins Hotel musste.
Und habe dann einfach so bei Booking geguckt, was ist denn in der Nähe von der
Autobahn, dass ich morgens direkt weiterfahre.
Habe gesehen, geil, da ist ein Hotel mit Whirlpool im Zimmer.
Und dann so nach ein paar Tagen.
Nur am Waschbecken waschen oder nur so eine kalte Dusche, so,
oh geil, ja, ja, so, das sozusagen als Ausgleich, also auch so,
ja, wo man einfach sagt, wie geil ist dieser Luxus, in dem wir leben.
So gemessen an dem, was halt echt eine Autotagfahrt weiters,
oder eine Flugstunde im Prinzip oder anderthalb, also das ist ja so wie nach
Barcelona fliegen ungefähr,
bis zur Das ist so halbwegs die gleiche Distanz und sind halt zwei ganz verschiedene Welten.
Es ist ja auch so, dass sehr viele geflüchtet sind aus der Ukraine,
natürlich vor allem die Leute, die unmittelbar von dem ursprünglichen Einmarsch
betroffen waren in den östlichen,
südlichen Gebieten, aber natürlich auch in vielen anderen Bereichen des Landes.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es so klare Zahlen darüber gibt, wie viele Leute die
Ukraine jetzt wirklich verlassen haben.
Da gibt es alle möglichen Zahlen.
Also ich habe so zwischen 5 und 15 Millionen, je nach Ecke gehört.
Ich habe es auch ein paar Mal versucht zu googeln oder so. Zum einen,
dann kam ich erst drauf, wer zählt das?
Da steht ja keiner mit einem Klick-Counter an der Grenze oder so.
Und ich vermute nicht, dass das irgendwie zentral erfasst wird,
so wie viele Bürger sind im Land oder so.
Wahrscheinlich am besten sind wahrscheinlich wieder die Mobilfunkanbieter,
wenn man die sagt, wie viel Prozent sind nicht mehr hier eingebucht oder sowas.
Aber ja, das fand ich auch spannend, dass es, oder zumindest habe ich keine
wirklich belastbaren, verlässlichen Zahlen gefunden, sondern nur so einen Raum,
in dem es sich irgendwie abspielt.
Also wenn man der Wikipedia folgt, hatte die Ukraine Anfang 2020 44 Millionen
Einwohner und wird jetzt mit ungefähr 37 Millionen angegeben.
Was in etwa 7 Millionen sind und vielleicht sind es halt auch ein paar mehr, who knows.
Das ist auf jeden Fall signifikant. Wenn also so viele auf einmal nicht mehr
da sind, reißen ja dann auch schon sehr viele persönliche Verbindungen ab und
es schwächt natürlich auch noch das Land.
Dazu kommt eben auch, dass glaube ich viele nachvollziehbarerweise,
die im Prinzip für die Armee eingezogen werden können, versuchen das so in irgendeiner Form zu umgehen.
Wo man natürlich sagen kann, warum hilfst du deinem Land nicht,
aber auf der anderen Seite kann man sich auch selber irgendwie fragen,
wie viel Leben hast du denn?
Also wie ich ja gerne auf Twitter sage, mit dem fetten Arsch auf der warmen
Couch im NATO-geschützten Land kann man immer eine Menge Meinung haben.
Also du musstest die Entscheidung nie treffen.
Und auch da ist es auch wieder so, ich könnte mir nicht mal vorstellen,
wie es ist, diese Entscheidung zu treffen.
Also ich weiß halt vor 20 Jahren, als es darum ging, zur Bundeswehr zu verweigern,
was ja bei meinem Alter schon trivial war. Man hat halt das Kreuz gemacht bei ich verweigere.
Das war jetzt kein Akt oder so, es war nur so, will ich dies oder das.
Und alleine da muss man drüber so ein bisschen abwägen zumindest,
wohin will ich hier. Aber...
Ich meine, bei denen von der Ukraine gibt es keine offiziellen Verlustquoten
oder so, aber dass nicht alle überleben, ist ja auch klar.
Ja, also ich kann es keinem sozusagen ankreiden, der keinen Bock hat, in den Krieg zu gehen.
Also das finde ich dann auch immer ein bisschen sehr billig,
wenn Leute in Deutschland dann sagen, dann verteidige doch dein Land.
Ja, du musstest hier nie was verteidigen, du musstest hier nie irgendwas tun, um das Land zu erhalten.
Also das Maß der Dinge ist hier, dass du alle vier Jahre deine Stimme abgibst
bei einer Wahl und nicht mal das kriegen alle hin.
– Abgesehen davon, dass die Leute natürlich sehr unter Druck sind,
persönlich ist vor allem auch die Infrastruktur ja extrem unter Druck.
Das ist auch so ein Punkt, den wir relativ wenig gecovert haben hier bisher,
weil es halt auch etwas schwierig nachzuvollziehen ist.
Es gibt zwar viele Meldungen, aber natürlich aus guten Gründen wird auch jetzt
das totale Ausmaß nicht unbedingt auch immer so kommuniziert.
Vielleicht wird es auch teilweise überkommuniziert.
Es gibt die Aussage, dass ein Großteil oder fast alles der Heizinfrastruktur,
der Heizkraftwerke ausgefallen sei oder zumindest in Schaden gekommen sein soll.
Es gab diverse Angriffe in den letzten Monaten, speziell auf Staudämme,
Kraftwerke, Wasserkraftwerke.
Die Stromerzeugung ist natürlich immer ein Ziel. Teilweise konnten ja,
also wir hatten ja vor einem Jahr.
War es ja richtig schlimm. Da haben ja die Russen extrem hochgefahren vor dem
Winter und da war es ein richtiger Kampf für die Ukraine,
weil vor allem halt die Waffenlieferungen gefehlt haben, insbesondere im Bereich der Verteidigung.
Also dass man einfach entsprechende Luftwehrabwehrsysteme nicht hatte,
beziehungsweise nicht in den Mengen hatte, wie das jetzt der Fall ist,
auch wenn es immer noch zu wenig zu sein scheint.
Also seitdem sind ja dann diverse Patriot-Systeme geliefert worden oder zumindest
wurde die Lieferung zugesagt, das weiß ich jetzt nicht so ganz genau.
Aber auch diese Systeme sind ja auch nur so gut, wie man sie eben entsprechend
mit Munition ausrüsten kann, Personal hat etc.
Training. Was ist so dein Eindruck, wie sehr die Infrastruktur Schaden genommen
hat und wo steht da die Ukraine?
Also wie nah an so einem Kipppunkt ist das?
Zum einen, ich meine da auch wieder den Punkt von gerade mit einbeziehen,
es sind ja 20 Prozent weniger Leute im Land ungefähr, also je nachdem wie man es rechnet.
Das heißt rein rechnerisch, wenn es 20 Prozent erwischen würde,
müsste es ja noch gut gehen.
Also kann man ja sagen, es muss deutlich mehr kaputt sein inzwischen.
Was ich halt im Alltag merke, ist halt wirklich so Sachen wie Wasser geht nicht
mehrmals am Tag und dann geht es wieder. Also so ein bisschen wie zufällig.
Also so hatte ich auch mal gefragt, woran das liegt, aber es konnte auch keiner so erklären.
Also die Erklärung war, weil es kaputt ist. Sagt, ja, ja, soweit war ich schon.
In Kiew, manchmal in Odessa.
Ja, in Odessa zum Beispiel, ich glaube im Mai war ich da, da ist die Hauptwasserleitung,
die nach Odessa geht zum Beispiel, getroffen worden oder sabotiert worden.
Das war zu der Zeit noch ein bisschen unklar. dann war quasi in der ganzen Stadt
erstmal ein paar Stunden Wasser weg.
Also außer die, die halt die großen Hotels haben oft riesen Tanks für sowas.
Das war auch bizarr. Unsere Nachbarn von dem Hotel, in dem ich war,
hatten keinen Strom, kein Wasser und kein Internet.
Und bei mir im Hotel lief alles und sogar die Sauna war an, weil sie die am
Generator haben laufen lassen.
Also so bevor sie dem Nachbarn Kabel rüberwerfen, erstmal den Spa-Bereich anschmeißen.
Das fand ich auch so sehr beeindruckend zum Thema Solidarität.
Das hat manchmal ein bisschen Unwucht.
Und dann auch so Sachen, wenn zum Beispiel auch in Odessa der Strom länger weg
war, hat man gemerkt, man hatte zwar noch Handyempfang und auch Internetempfang,
aber das ging immer weiter runter.
Also so wie wenn die Akkus von den Sendemasten ausgehen oder so und man mit
immer mehr Leuten immer weniger Infrastruktur teilt.
Und auch so, erst hatten wir noch im Hotelempfang und dann sozusagen ein Stück
vor der Tür und da musste man bis auf die Kreuzung gehen, wo irgendwie offensichtlich
ein Signal von ein Stück weiter weg kam.
Also nie, dass man ganz offline war, aber schon, dass man merkte,
da irgendwie ging es deutlich runter und dann war irgendwie Strom wieder da
und es sprang so um wieder auf 5G.
Wir alle wissen, schlechtes Internet ist schlimmer als gar kein Internet.
Genau, das absolut. Also auch so wie so früher mit UUCP so ein bisschen.
Man hat die Mails und die WhatsApps geschrieben, dann ist man in die Mitte von
der Kreuzung gegangen, dann ging so einmal alles raus und der Empfang kam und
da hat man nachgelesen und geantwortet.
Also wie echt so Usenet in den 80ern, das ging ja auch gut.
Und also selbst in den großen Städten und sozusagen je kleiner es wird,
desto mehr solche Sachen, also desto länger Stromausfälle.
Und auch zum Teil in den Dörfern haben die ja eh keine Heizung im Haus,
sondern du hast einen Ofen.
Das fand ich auch krass, was ich so gar nicht mehr gewohnt bin von hier,
dass man halt so über Land fährt und es riecht überall nach diesen Holzöfen oder Kohleöfen.
Also das Einzige, wo ich mich so ganz, ganz vage noch daran erinnern kann,
sodass das in der DDR manchmal so war, aber ich meine, ich war sechs, als die DDR zu Ende ging.
Ich kann sagen, so Ost-Berlin nach der Wende hatte definitiv einen anderen Geruch
im Osten als im Westen und das war dann auch, das hat mir auch jemand aus dem Osten damals erzählt,
das hätte er immer nicht geglaubt, als ihm seine Freunde erzählt haben,
im Westen würde es anders riechen, aber das war definitiv der Fall.
Ja genau und das halt, wo man so merkt, ja also auf jeden Fall die Alltagsinfrastruktur
geht schon runter und eben die ganz essentiellen Sachen wie halt Wasser und
Strom regelmäßig, dass es da,
also bei Strom habe ich auch wirklich stundenlange auch so 10-Stunden-Ausfälle oder sowas erlebt.
Teilweise machen die ja geplante Abschaltungen, also das heißt von 10 bis 12
hat das Stadtviertel Strom,
von 12 bis 2 das und dann ladet alle eure Akkus in der Zeit und auch ein Anwalt,
mit dem ich damals zu tun hatte, sagte, der teilt sich quasi mit drei anderen
Anwälten gerade ein Büro und die rotieren sozusagen 10 bis 12 bei ihm,
12 bis 2 bei dem, also wo gerade Strom ist, wenn sie halt arbeiten müssen.
Und dann gibt es aber eben auch diese Ungeplanten, wo einfach Strom ausfällt.
Also weil da irgendwo, also erstmal für Verteidigung Krankenhäuser und sowas benutzt wird.
Ist auch komisch, so Leute, die neben einem Krankenhaus wohnen,
haben dann zum Beispiel immer Strom, weil sie mit an dem Verteiler oder so hängen.
Oder auch so ein Apartment, was ich immer wieder in Kiew gemietet hatte, das hatte immer Strom.
Und dann hatten wir auch gefragt, ob jemand eine Idee hat und die haben alle so rumgedruckst.
Und irgendwann sagten welche, ja, sie haben immer schon die Vermutung gehabt,
dass nebenan der Geheimdienst sitzt.
Und so, also jetzt will da jetzt niemand klingeln und fragen,
aber sie haben halt immer Strom in diesem Block.
Naja gut, Prioritäten. Ja genau, genau. Nur wo man halt merkt,
wirklich so bis in den Alltag runter, dass man schon merkt, ja,
da ist ganz deutlich was kaputt.
Und mit der Heizung, also ich meine jetzt, wir mussten nicht heizen,
deswegen schwer zu sagen, wie viel da kaputt ist.
Das sehen wir im Winter wieder. Ich erinnere mich, im letzten Jahr.
Hatten wir, also selbst in den Apartments, in denen wir gewohnt hatten,
oft so lange Unterwäsche und Schlafsäcke oder so bei, also dass man einfach
ein paar Schichten anziehen kann, wenn es zu kalt wird.
Und dann das nächste Problem ist, wenn die Heizung nicht geht,
holen die Leute halt Heizlüfter.
Und dann hast du halt irgendwie 5000 Watt oder so pro Wohnung,
die du dann an Strom bräuchtest.
Das ist dann das nächste Problem.
Aber ja, vor allem bin ich gespannt dann dieses Jahr, weil ich glaube nicht,
dass die so viel in Stand gesetzt bekommen davon zur Zeit.
Oder zumindest, also ich meine Strom und Grundsätze, also auch so Details,
in manchen Orten stand, dass man das Wasser aus der Leitung nicht trinken soll.
Also dass sie offensichtlich zwar Wasserdruck hinbekommen, aber nicht mehr ausreichend
Kapazitäten haben, um es zu reinigen richtig oder sich zumindest nicht sicher sind.
Also so, wo man merkt, so langsam von erster Welt kippt es so zu zweiter bis
dritter Welt oder so. Also ich kann sagen, ähnlich wie in Kurdistan.
Man sagt, da geht in der Moll mal fünf Minuten das Licht aus,
bis die Generatoren an sind und man trinkt kein Wasser aus der Leitung.
Nur war man es halt in der Ukraine nicht mehr gewohnt. Also es ist so von deutschem
Standard auf so Kurdistan gerutscht, so in etwa.
War eine große diskussion im zusammenhang ist ja sozusagen der zustand der atomkraftwerke
ukraine hat ja traditionell sehr
viel atomkraft tatsächlich war die energiesituation ja so gut dass die,
Ukraine ja noch während des Kriegs Strom nach Europa exportiert hat.
Davon sind wir jetzt weit entfernt. Immerhin, Glück im Unglück,
war es ja glaube ich auch so, dass die Anbindung an das europäische Stromnetz
schon lange geplant war.
Und darüber natürlich jetzt auch entsprechend Strom, zumindest für Teilbereiche der Ukraine,
also wahrscheinlich Lviv und diese Gegend im Westen, dass die eben aus Polen
heraus bedient werden kann.
Aber jetzt sind ja, einerseits haben wir die Inehoda-Situation,
also das von den Russen besetzte Atomkraftwerk, was ja abgeschaltet ist,
aber immer noch mit Strom, mit Notstrom versorgt werden muss,
um diesen Zustand sozusagen sicher zu halten.
Aber die anderen Atomkraftwerke, was hast du da gehört, was deren Zustand ist
und inwiefern die gefährdet zu sein scheinen?
Also zum einen gefährdet sehen da alle, dass es eine große Gefährdung ist und
alle haben Sorge, nicht mal, dass die bombardiert werden oder so,
sondern dass irgendwelche Störfälle provoziert werden.
Also eben, dass man die Notstromsachen sabotiert und dann die Stromleitung da hinweg oder so.
Ich meine, das Unglück in Tschernobyl war ja auch ganz grob,
dass sie, mal salopp gesagt, die Notstromübungen falsch gemacht haben und das dann aus dem Ruder lief.
Und sowas in dieser Richtung quasi provozieren. Also dass man nachher sagt,
ach komm, ihr und eure Sowjet-Technik, klar geht das kaputt,
aber wenn man sozusagen den ganzen Strom oder dafür sorgt, dass es nicht mehr
ordentlich gekühlt wird,
kann man das ja, sagen wir, deutlich wahrscheinlicher machen.
Und auch zu der Stromanbindung, diese große Stromtrasse ist ja in der Nähe von
Lviv, die nach Polen geht.
Und man war das vor ein oder anderthalb Jahren, ist ja diese Teile von einer
Rakete oder von zweien in Polen abgestürzt hinter der Grenze.
Und die Vermutung war, dass die Russen halt auf die Stromtrasse geschossen haben
und eine ukrainische Abwehrrakete, also das dann halt verhindert hat und sie
dabei dann eben die Trümmer über die Grenze geschleudert haben.
Es war wohl das ganze Geschehen sehr dicht an dieser Stromtrasse,
also dass es eine gewisse Wahrscheinlichkeit gab, dass sie das da kappen wollten,
um eben zu verhindern, dass davon weiter, also ja wirklich Riesenmengen Strom kommen.
Also nicht wie so ein Verlängerungskabel, sondern halt so eine Anbindung für ein halbes Land halt.
Ja und das Einatomkraftwerk bei Rivne ungefähr,
ich weiß nicht genau wie das heißt, aber da in der Ecke ist eins,
da gab es ja auch kleinere Angriffe drauf, bei denen Drohnen und sowas in die Nähe flogen.
Also da gab es ja immer schon wieder jetzt Sachen, dass man Sorge hatte oder
dass es, also ist eigentlich auch wieder der Punkt bei Terror,
man muss ja nicht mal, man muss das Ding ja nicht mal treffen,
eigentlich man muss nicht mal unbedingt einen Störfall provozieren,
aber alleine wenn man die ganze Zeit dafür sorgt, dass die Leute Angst haben,
dass was passieren könnte, dann hat der Terror ja schon fast seinen Zweck erfüllt.
Also wie halt in Kiew, wenn ich da bin, fühle ich mich relativ sicher und trotzdem
reicht es ja, wenn einmal im Monat ein Apartment mit einer Person getroffen
wird, dass jeder wieder denkt, nächstes Mal könnte ich es sein.
Ja und das scheint ja auch die klare Strategie der Russen an der Stelle zu sein.
Ich meine, wenn man sich anschaut, wie viel Munition auch große Missiles,
Iskander-Raketen, die hunderte von Millionen kosten,
einfach dafür verwendet werden,
nachrangige Infrastruktur und Wohngebäude zu zerstören,
dann hat das natürlich keinen militärstrategischen Grund, Sondern dann kann
die einzige Erklärung, also abgesehen von Inkompetenz, die man natürlich nie
ganz ausschließen darf,
kann die einzige Erklärung eigentlich nur sein, dass es eben generell um Terror
geht im eigentlichen Sinne.
Also Angst erzeugen und den Gegner dadurch schwächen, dass man eben so einen
permanenten Zustand von Angst im Raum erhält.
Ja und auch viele von diesen großen Raketen haben ja auch nur eine Genauigkeit
von 100, 200 Metern, wo man auch sagen kann, du könntest nicht mal das eine
Wohnhaus treffen, was du treffen willst.
Also jetzt nicht wie im Libanon, dass man sagt und wir schicken das Ding genau
auf den Hisbollah-Führer, sondern es ist so ungefähr dieser Wohnbereich.
Also nicht mal, dass es möglich wäre, eine Person da speziell zu treffen.
Und dass es wirkt, sieht man ja an den Millionen Leuten, die gegangen sind.
Also jetzt mal, wenn man Pavel hier hätte und sagt, mal das doch mal mathematisch
auf, dann würde man wahrscheinlich sagen, hey, die Chance da zu sterben ist echt gering.
Also jetzt wirklich die Chance nicht im Kampfeinsatz, sondern als Zivilist in
der Ukraine zu sterben, stochastisch ist die nicht hoch.
Aber trotzdem will keiner von den Millionen Leuten, die hoch gegen der 0,1 Promille
oder so sein. Nein. Und ja, sieht man, funktioniert.
Millionen Leute in die EU getrieben und obwohl wir keine Probleme in dem Sinne
mit denen haben, trotzdem für politische Unruhe hier auch gesorgt.
Also ich meine immer bei denen, die empfänglich für Rassismus und so weiter
sind, aber trotzdem, auch die Nummer klappt ja.
Und, jetzt nicht direkt mit dem Konflikt zu tun, aber so halb,
als dann über Putin so die Idee kam, Kurden und auch andere,
aber Kurden, Araber und so aus Syrien, Irak und so nach Belarus zu schicken
und an die polnische Grenze zu schieben.
Es hatte ja auch nur den Zweck, dass in der EU die Fernsehbilder entstehen von was machen wir jetzt.
Und dass halt die einen sagen, also die Rassisten sagen, ja,
wir murksen die alle ab, dass die nicht über die Grenze kommen.
Und die anderen sagen, ey, sind Menschen, die müssen alle rein.
Ja, super, du hast irgendwie drei Flugzeuge gesponsert mit Leuten,
die nicht mal unbedingt auf dem Weg hierhin wollten, die die Gelegenheit genutzt
haben und du hast einen halben Kontinent in eine Diskussion gestürzt.
Also auch so war ja da wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht der Hauptzweck,
mit den Flüchtlingen so sozusagen Diskussionen oder so ungemacht Politisches so hochzubringen.
Aber es ist halt immer noch auch noch so ein Nebeneffekt, den man halt hat.
Und wir sehen es ja hier in den Wahlergebnissen auch wieder.
Also es ist ja nicht nur deswegen, aber sagen wir, Ukraine ist ja doch ein relevantes,
also es ist so bescheuert.
Außenpolitik ist ein relevantes Thema in Landtagswahlen geworden,
die überhaupt nichts damit zu tun haben. Also das zeigt ja schon die Blödheit
von dieser ganzen Sache.
Ich meine, ein interessanter Punkt, den du da ansprichst, ist ja der Einfluss
sozusagen der Russen auf den Westen.
Und wer sich mit der Situation auch nur ein bisschen beschäftigt,
sieht das halt einfach, der Einfluss ist sehr groß.
Er geht direkt auf Parteien, AfD, BSW werden von ausrussischen Quellen ernährt,
andere Parteien in Europa genauso.
Man sieht ja auch, wie Orban in Ungarn klar Partei ergreift.
Slowakei ist da auch ein bisschen problematisch und es gibt natürlich auch noch
ein paar andere Länder in der EU, die jetzt potenziell in Gefahr sind.
Österreich hat sich jetzt gerade mal wieder eine FPÖ-Mehrheit,
also Mehrheit im Sinne von sie haben die meisten Stimmen bekommen.
Wie es dann jetzt mit der Regierungsbildung ausgeht, ist ja nochmal eine andere
Frage, aber man sieht schon, es ist teilweise relativ einfach,
unsere wohlstandsverwahrlosten Westländer in Unruhe zu bringen.
Es hat vorher beim Brexit schon funktioniert, das alte Ding mit irgendwie die
anderen sind schuld und die bösen Ausländer nehmen uns was auch immer weg, so.
Man muss sich keine Illusionen mehr machen, dass das einfach immer verfangen
wird bei sehr vielen Leuten.
Die Frage ist halt immer nur, wie sehr kriegt man das in so einem zivilen Prozess
noch so eingehegt, dass es eben keine Dominanz hat.
Aber das wissen die Russen auch und nehmen halt Einfluss. Und sie nehmen halt
Einfluss über Wege, die wir heute noch sehr schlecht unter Kontrolle kriegen,
insbesondere natürlich das Internet, soziale Medien, Messenger, Kanäle etc.
Diese permanente Flut von Fehlinformationen, von Disinformationen,
der scheinen wir so recht nicht gewachsen zu sein.
Ja, also ein Puzzleteil scheint mir, dass man mit selbstgewählter Blödheit immer weiterkommt im Leben.
Also ich habe das Gefühl früher, wenn du blöd warst, hast du irgendwann ein
Problem gehabt, weil du irgendwo nicht weiterkamst. Und jetzt,
wenn du zu blöd oder wenn viele Leute zu blöd sind, dann wird die Welt um sie
rum gebaut, sodass sie mit ihrer Blödheit immer weiterkommen.
Also so wie betreutes Blödsein.
Und dann fehlt ja auch ein Anreiz, also schon so bei einfachen Sachen da rauszukommen.
Also zum einen bei Schildern, die Dinge erklären, wo man denkt,
ernsthaft, da habt ihr jetzt irgendwie ein Schild, also so wie an einer Tür,
was weiß ich, hatte ich vor einer Weile gesehen, dass man die Türklinke drücken
muss, damit die Tür aufgeht.
Dachte, ich würde das Schild nicht anbringen, weil dann stehst du halt draußen,
das merkst du irgendwann.
Oder du gehst nach Hause, hast halt ein Problem, aber in einer öffentlichen Einrichtung.
Zweisprachig, deutsch und englisch, an einer Tür mit Türklinke,
dass man die Türklinke runterdrücken muss und dann die Tür, also jetzt nicht
mal, dass man sagt, ey, hier ist ein Spezialfall, du musst die hoch und um die
Ecke biegen oder so, sondern eine Türklinke.
Das war jetzt aber nicht die Behörde, wo US-Amerikaner um EU...
Zum Glück nicht, zum Glück nicht. Aber trotzdem, es gibt ja eine Menge so Sachen,
wo mir einfach immer scheint,
Es wird halt immer mehr Rücksicht genommen, also auf Leute, die sich eigenständig
dämlich halten, weil sie keinen Bock haben.
Dann heißt es immer, man muss ja aber Rücksicht auf die nehmen, man muss helfen.
Scheint immer, das ist so ein Puzzlestück, weil, also auch wenn es jetzt heißt,
ja TikTok macht die Leute blöd, mal salopp gesagt.
Denkt, naja, also wenn ich jetzt einem hochgebildeten Menschen TikTok gebe,
dann guckt er sich das an und lacht und geht weiter. Aber wird ja nicht blöd
davon, dass er die App aufmacht.
Das ist ja ein paar Ebenen komplizierter, sagen wir mal.
Sondern das Problem ist ja blöde, also Leute, die, sagen wir,
empfänglich für Blödsinn sind und keinen eigenen Anspruch haben,
sich eigenständig zu bilden oder was zu hinterfragen und so.
Also nur das ist auch sowas, wo es dann hieß, müssen wir TikTok verbieten,
wo ich denke, hey und dann werden alle schlau oder wie, nee,
dann sind die genauso blöd und haben sie keinen TikTok, dann finden sie halt das Nächste.
Also dass die App zur Zeit im Fokus steht oder Telegram-Kanäle, klar,
aber die sind ja nicht das Problem oder da geht es ja nicht los,
sondern so, wenn wir beide uns jetzt TikTok angucken, dann sagen wir danach
nicht, boah, ich will jetzt BSW und du AfD, ich bin überzeugt,
sondern wir sagen, Mann, ist das dämlich. also so und oder.
Ist das gefährlich?
Ja genau also so je nach genau also so wie kann sowas dämliches so gefährlich
sein eigentlich die also ich gucke mir auch so einen Scheiß immer an und denke
so das ist doch so doof also es ist doch so es ist so hanebüchen,
Dumm das allermeiste davon, wie blöd muss man denn sein, dass man dafür empfänglich
ist und dann sagt man, okay, knapp 50 Prozent. so.
Ja, ich meine, ich würde gar nicht
mal sagen, dass es was mit Dummheit im eigentlichen Sinne zu tun hat.
Klar mag es bei Leuten da auch kognitive Einschränkungen geben,
aber es ist halt die Repetition und die Masse und die Menge und die Viralität, die es halt so,
annimmt, ne, weil weiß nicht, also ich hab das auch neulich mal gemacht,
mal so TikTok gestartet ohne Account, ohne irgendein,
irgendeine History sozusagen, weil ich das halt einfach Einfach nur bestenfalls
mal auf Zuruf mal im Web mal was anschaue und die Menge an Hass,
die mir also einfach schon von Anfang an da entgegen kam,
neben den ganzen Produktwerbungen, das war einfach krass.
Also es war einfach, als gäbe es gar kein anderes Thema.
Und das ist natürlich etwas, dem sich ein Mensch auch nur begrenzt entgegenstellen
kann, wenn das dann halt auf einmal deine Realitätswahrnehmung ist.
Weil natürlich suchst du in diesen Medien nach Orientierung.
Das ist ja vollkommen normal.
Das tun wir ja auch. Wir wollen ja auch irgendwie uns mit Nachrichten versorgen,
um ein möglichst gutes Weltbild zu bekommen und einschätzen zu können, was die Bedrohung ist.
Aber wenn dann halt irgendwelche Hoshis da angelaufen kommen und sagen,
die Bedrohung ist die Ukraine und ja, dann geht das schnell.
Ja, ich merke auch viel, dass auch Menschen, die ich so für,
sagen wir, halbwegs normal gebildet halte, also nicht Leute,
wo man hingeht und sagt, okay,
der ist einfach, der ist blöd, weil er blöd sein will, sondern Leute,
die zum Teil, die studiert haben, die halbwegs Medien konsumieren,
aber sagt so, also denen man einen gewissen Bildungsgrad zurechnet.
Und da gab es nur eine, also nur so eine exemplarische Geschichte,
ein Bekannter hatte mir gesagt, eine NGO, mit der ich zu tun habe,
die zwacken halt Geld für private Zwecke ab. Sagt, okay.
Das ist nicht gut. Also hast du irgendwie irgendwas, wo kommt die Story her
oder so, weil das würde mich schon sehr interessieren.
Ja, das hat ein Bekannter gesagt. Ja, okay, und was, also so,
wo geht die Story jetzt los?
Ja, weil der eine Gründer von, oder ein Vorstand oder so von dem Dingen,
der ist gerade in den USA.
Ja, okay, du musst schon in ganzen Sätzen sprechen. Ja, wo hat der denn das
Geld her? Das muss er ja dann da rausgenommen haben.
Und man kann sich ja vorstellen, das war so die ganze Argumentation,
wo so in einer kleinen Bubble oder in so einer Nischenbubble sich alle sicher
waren, die greifen an die Kasse.
Hat irgendjemand irgendwie mal einen Ansatz, woher das kommt oder warum ihr meint, das ist so?
Naja, das finden sie ganz logisch. Und also auch sowas dachte ich,
wie dann so ein völliger Bullshit ohne Grundlage entsteht, weil jemand in den
USA ist, ich hatte ihn dann nachher mal gefragt, was hast du denn in den USA gemacht?
Er war halt zu so einer Art NGO-Konferenz eingeladen, die irgendwie von UN oder
State Department oder so finanziert ist und Dingen halt.
Deswegen ist er da hingeflogen und er hat nicht mal einen Cent für bezahlt.
Also es war mit einer Frage auch geklärt, dass selbst der kleinste Ansatz nicht
stimmt, wo ich dachte, das hat sich da so im Kreis gedreht, aber null Personen
haben auch nochmal gesagt, ergibt das Sinn?
Kann das sein? Oder haben wir einen Ansatz? Also, und wenn das schon bei so
Leuten ist, denke ich, klar, also dieses,
also ich meine sozusagen die Bubble, aus der wir kommen, da kannst du ja sagen,
der Tisch hier ist weiß und da sagt einer, warte, ich hole das Messgerät,
das will ich jetzt erstmal prüfen, ich sage, das ist, da sind aber locker drei
Prozent schwarz drin, ne.
Und so war es, also so, dass alles hinter, also so, ne, Misstraueautoritäten
und alles hinterfragen und gucken und selber verstehen, wie es geht und so,
RTFM, ne, so, guck in die Anleitungen, versteh doch das.
Und das ist für mich auch immer noch so eine Grundlage halt, so von Leben einfach.
Also ich will mir ja nicht selber blöd vorkommen. Ich glaube,
das ist das Problem. Die Leute kommen sich ja auch nicht blöd vor.
So Verschwörungstheoretiker kommen sich ja meist sehr elitär und gebildet vor.
Ja und ich denke es ist natürlich auch ein Bedürfnis für viele Leute für sich
ein schlüssiges Weltbild zu haben und das haben sie sich natürlich über das wenige Wissen,
was sie vielleicht bekommen haben so aufgebaut und dann sucht man natürlich
auch sehr schnell und das kenne ich auch von mir selbst, muss ich ehrlich zugeben.
Man sucht dann nach Bestätigung für dieses bisher gewonnene Weltbild und tendiert dazu,
alle Nachrichten, die in eine andere Richtung gehen und die dieses Weltbild
in Frage stellen, erstmal beiseite zu lassen und sich lieber an irgendwelche
Sachen ranzuhängen, die dann bestätigen, was man sowieso schon denkt.
Weil dann fühlt man sich halt schlauer, dann fühlt man sich sozusagen bei den Gewinnern.
Das ist so dieses Do-Your-Own-Research, was damit halt eigentlich gemeint ist.
Such dir die Informationen, die deinen bisherigen Blick bestätigen und ignoriere alles andere.
Und das ist glaube ich eine sehr starke Kraft, die man nicht unterschätzen darf
und die halt einfach durch diese ganzen viralen Mechanismen,
die wir derzeit im Internet sehen und durch diese Plattformen verstärkenden
Mechanismen halt noch weiter befördert werden. Ja.
Aber lass uns wieder zurück zur Ukraine kommen, auch wenn das sicherlich alles
eine große Rolle spielt.
Jetzt warst du ja vor Ort, das haben wir ja schon angesprochen.
Wo hat dich denn die Reise zuerst hingeführt und also jetzt im Osten,
wo gab es für dich neue Eindrücke, was kannst du von dort berichten?
Also erstmal, wir sind von Kiew aus über Charkiv nach Kramatorsk gefahren.
Das fand ich schon ganz interessant, weil das aus meiner Sicht ein bisschen ein Bogen ist.
Man könnte auch über Denipro fahren und von Denipro in die Gegend hieß es aber,
sei gefährlicher als über Charkiv. Das ist schon beeindruckend,
weil Kharkiv an sich eigentlich die ganze Zeit nie so richtig sicher war.
Also mal sehr unsicher, mal ein bisschen unsicher.
Aber wenn das der sichere Weg ist, dann ist schon ein bisschen blöd.
Und auch als wir da durchfuhren.
Also man muss dazu sagen, gerade Rakiv hat in den letzten Wochen wieder sehr
viele Raketeneinschläge erlebt,
da sind viele Wohnhäuser angegriffen worden, mitten in der Stadt,
also man hat wieder so eine Situation, wo so eine alltägliche Permanentbedrohung
durch Raketenbeschuss wieder da ist.
Und auch als wir dann da vorbeifuhren, also sobald man Richtung Osten fährt,
hat man fast durchgehend immer Raketenalarm irgendwo in der Ecke.
Achso und was man vielleicht auch nochmal sagen sollte, für Leute,
die da nicht so drinstecken.
Kharkiv ist die zweitgrößte Stadt in der Ukraine.
Es ist jetzt nicht so ein kleiner Fleck, sondern das ist sozusagen neben Kiew
einfach das wichtigste Zentrum.
Und vor allem auch so, dass traditionell war es eben das russischsprachige Zentrum
der Ukraine. Also dort wurde mehrheitlich russisch gesprochen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das immer noch so ist.
Ich glaube, es wandelt sich natürlich langsamer da, wo das nicht mehr drin war.
Es sind halt 50, 60 Kilometer nach Russland oder so.
Also es war halt so, wie du schon sagst, es war total enge mit Russland.
Das ist wahrscheinlich so, wie manche Orte, so Nordrhein-Westfalen,
die an der niederländischen Grenze sind, wo man halt rüberfährt und Frikandel
holt und dann wieder zurückkommt oder so.
Also es war jetzt nicht wie zwei ganz separate Länder, sondern oft verwandter auf der anderen Seite.
Trotzdem deutsch, ich würde mal vielleicht eher so Saarland oder so.
Genau, oder eher sowas, genau. Aber so war man sagt schon dicht,
also verwandtschaftlich verwandt, man kannte das drüben und so.
Also nicht wie man sich so, das absolute Gegenteil von jetzt so Land im Krieg.
Genau, und als wir da so vorbeifuhren quasi, sagte die App auch,
hey, gab Einschläge in Charkiv.
Also man sagt, okay, wir sind sozusagen drum rum gefahren auf der Autobahn oder
Landstraße oder wie sich das da genau nennt.
Und dann ging es halt weiter rum. runter und als wir so an Kupiansk vorbeikamen,
also als wir da schon eine halbe Stunde ungefähr durch waren,
hieß es, ah, jetzt ist in Kupiansk was eingeschlagen.
Also man auch einfach so immer dran erinnert wird, ja, das ist schon immer noch wild, diese Ecke.
Du bist von Charkiv nach Kupiansk?
Nee, nee, wir sind also ein Stück vorbeigefahren, aber wir sind über Isium.
Also Charkiv, dann sind wir durch Isium und dann weiter runter nach Kramatorsk. Ich glaube, die IM3.
Das ist ja im Prinzip so durch das Gebiet, was von der Ukraine als erstes zurückerobert wurde.
Die große Kharkiv-Offensive der Ukraine war ja sehr erfolgreich und dort sind
die Russen über diesen Jenseits des Ostkiel-Flusses zurückgedrängt worden.
Dort ist derzeit auch eine sehr aktive Front.
Also gibt es verschiedene brenzlige Situationen, wo die Russen gerade alles
drauf schmeißen, um dort ein Gebiet abzutrennen.
Das sieht auch gerade so aus, als ob sie damit noch Erfolg haben könnten.
Muss man jetzt mal gucken, wie weit sie jetzt im Herbst noch kommen,
wenn der Schlamm einsetzt.
Aber das ist definitiv knapp und die Stadt Kupjans, wie du erwähnst,
ist ja ein ganz wichtiger strategischer Ort, der dann halt genau auf dieser
Flussbegrenzung auch liegt und ein ganz wichtiges Eisenbahnzentrum ist.
Das ist also definitiv so ein Ort, den die Ukraine auf jeden Fall halten sollte. Ja.
Okay, aber dann bist du dann sozusagen schräg durch dieses zurückeroberte Land gegangen.
Welchem Zustand befanden sich so die Orte, durch die du dann gereist bist?
Bist du jetzt nur durch die.
Hauptstraße und da ist es relativ gut.
Also das muss man sagen, das hatte ich später, wenn wir zu den anderen Orten kommen, war es anders.
Und halt dadurch, dass wir nachts gefahren sind, also nachts ist ja Ausgangssperre,
Also je nachdem, wo man ist, ob 21 Uhr bis 0 Uhr fängt die an und geht dann
bis 5, 6 Uhr im Normalfall.
Und da sind dann halt auch die ganzen Militärtransporte unterwegs.
Also tagsüber auch einige, aber nachts richtig viel.
Und dann sieht man immer, wo bewegt sich viel und wo nicht so viel.
Und in der Gegend war halt eine Menge so Schwertransporter mit Panzern und ähnlichem unterwegs.
Also von der einen Gegend zur anderen und zurück.
Und es gibt dann so auf der ganzen Strecke da ein, zwei wie so Parkplätze,
an denen es so ein paar Shops gibt mit wie so Würstchenbuden oder sowas.
Also einfach so fünf, sechs verschiedene Fressbuden sind und Parkplatz davor.
Und da gibt es zwei, die auch nachts die ganze Zeit aufhaben.
Also eigentlich ist halt Nachtruhe, aber die dürfen irgendwie halt so,
damit die Leute sich da was holen können, die vorbeifahren.
Und das ist auch immer ganz interessant.
Weil es halt so ein Schmelztiegel ist, so alle, die nachts im Donbass rumfahren,
halten irgendwie da, um sich eine Cola und ein Würstchen oder so zu holen.
Und dann hat man halt so eine Mischung aus Rettungskräften, Freiwilligen aus
allen Ländern der Welt, die irgendwie da unterwegs sind, riesige Militärtransporte
und auch immer wieder, was lustig ist.
Dann kommt man irgendwie rein und sobald die sehen, dass so ein Westler reinkommt
oder so, hört so eine kleine Gruppe in der Ecke auf zu reden und man fragt sich,
welche Sprache sprechen die?
Also warum sind das jetzt die Franzosen, sind das die Amis? Also warum sind die genau jetzt still?
Das ist auch immer ganz interessant. Aber man merkt es, da tummelt sich dann
alles auf so zehn Quadratmetern.
Also wie so ein Späti, wo halt dann so in den frühen Morgenstunden die Ersten
zur Arbeit kommen und die Letzten vom Feiern zurück oder so.
Und wo man so ganz wirre Mischungen hat.
Und dann ging es halt erst mal nach Kramatorsk, weil wir da gewohnt haben.
Eine Frage habe ich noch. Isium war ja eine Stadt, die relativ hart unter Beschuss gewesen ist.
Wie zerstört ist der Ort noch? Hast du das irgendwie mitbekommen?
Also wir sind nur so ein bisschen durchgefahren. Das, was ich gesehen habe, war okay.
Also schon ab und zu mal ein zerstörtes Gebäude, aber der Großteil sah okay
aus von dem, wo wir vorbeikamen.
Aber ich bin halt nicht in die Tiefe in dem Ort.
Also es kann halt gut sein, dass es abseits von der Hauptstraße anders aussieht.
Also ich weiß nur östlich von Isium, wenn man da in die Dörfer fährt,
ist es zum Teil so, dass einfach echt das ganze Dorf weggebombt ist und noch
irgendwo mal ein Dach drauf ist oder so.
Aber da gibt es so Gegenden, dass echt 90 Prozent entweder nur noch ein Krater
oder zumindest signifikant zerstört.
Und wo man halt auch merkt, in Kiew wird ja ganz schnell wieder aufgebaut zum
Beispiel, allein weil sie den Wohnraum brauchen, weil es ordentlich aussehen soll.
Und da je weiter nach Ostmann geht.
Desto mehr wird so gelassen. Also ich denke gerade, wenn es so eins der letzten
Dörfer ist sozusagen vom Kriegsgebiet, wo es immer wieder knallt und alle gehen,
warum soll man da auch irgendwas aufbauen?
Da hält man die Hauptstraße frei und vielleicht noch eine Tankstelle und das war es dann halbwegs.
Aber ist denn da Leben in der Stadt gewesen? Ja.
Hast du den Eindruck gehabt? Ja, ja.
Weil das ist ja jetzt von der Frontlinie ungefähr so 50 Kilometer entfernt.
Da ist ja so ungefähr, wenn es mehr als eine Artilleriereichweite ist,
dann ist meist Leben, also so mehr als 30, 35 Kilometer.
Und Isium, also ich meine, war auch früher keine Großstadt, aber da hat man
auch gesehen, da standen auch zivile Autos rum, da hatten halt so diese kleinen
Lebensmittelläden auf, also da schien es ziviles Leben auch noch zu geben.
Also relativ normal.
Weiter unten dann in Kramatorsk nicht mehr. Also dazwischen ist dann sozusagen,
also da kommt ja auch kein großer Ort dazwischen, aber das ist so halbwegs die Grenze.
In Isium sind noch so ein paar Leute und in Kramatorsk, da war dann also auch
Zerstörung gar nicht so viel zu sehen.
Also schon hier und da war es kaputt, aber jetzt nicht, wie man sich so ein
abgerauchtes Kriegsgebiet vorstellt.
Ähm, aber halt Militärfahrzeuge, aber gar nicht so sehr viel Militär,
sondern ganz viel diese so wie so gecrowdfundete Geländewagen,
also so meist so Nissan und Toyotas, 10,
15 Jahre alt, so mit der Farbrolle grün oder schwarz gemalt und ein paar Beulen dran.
Also das ist echt so das typische Auto, was man da sieht.
Also entweder von irgendwelchen Freiwilligen oder von Soldaten,
die das selber irgendwo gekauft haben.
Also alles, was Allradantrieb hat und was man grün anmalen konnte und was ein
bisschen Bodenfreiheit hat, so das fährt da irgendwie rum.
Es gibt auch so ganz klassische Schäden, die man oft sieht. Zum Beispiel viele
Autos haben ja am Radkasten noch so eine Plastikverkleidung,
damit man nicht irgendwo anstößt oder so.
Und wenn einem der Reifen platzt, dann ist das meist das Erste, was wegfliegt.
Und dann hat man da so wie so eine ausgerissene Verkleidung,
haben so die Hälfte der Autos da. Also bei den Straßen kann man sich vorstellen,
der Hälfte ist mal der Hinterreifen geplatzt und diese Plastikverkleidung flog weg.
Aber es ist auch so ein Punkt, wenn man das einmal kennt, dann fällt einem das
unglaublich viel auf, dass man sagt, okay, es spricht halt für schlechte Straßen
oder schlechte Reifen oder beides.
Und das sah man so in Kramatorsk, dass das so das Hauptfahrzeug war,
weil man hat halt fast keine...
Seien wir normalen zivilen Fahrzeuge mehr gesehen oder sowas?
Kramatorsk war ja schon immer das militär-logistische Zentrum im Donbass,
schon vor der Großinvasion,
also schon die ganzen Kämpfe im Donbass seit 2014 wurden im Wesentlichen von
Kramatorsk aus koordiniert, wenn ich das richtig mitbekommen habe.
Aber dementsprechend war das schon immer so eine stark militärisch geprägte
Stadt, aber seit der Großinvasion war dann die Fluchtwelle ja relativ groß.
Es gab ja dann diesen Raketeneinschlag direkt in die… Auf dem Vorplatz des Bahnhofs, ja.
Genau beim Bahnhof, wo leider auch noch dann viele quasi auf den letzten Metern
ihrer Flucht ums Leben gekommen sind.
Und halt genau in der Evakuierungsphase, also ja nicht eine Woche vor oder später,
hätte es wahrscheinlich kaum jemand, also ganz wenig erwischt.
Das war halt, ja und es war halt dieser, also kann man sich ja vorstellen,
so ein Haupteingang zum Bahnhof mit so einer Art, wie so eine Busvorfahrt oder
so eine Wendeschleife davor, also so der Vorplatz oder wie man das nennen will.
Und genau da ist das Ding halt eingeschlagen, also genau so an dem,
ja also da wo so Taxis, Busse und so ein Kram halt immer ist.
Und ja, also ganz offensichtlich gezielt und also sehen jetzt die Zuschauer nicht,
aber für dich da bei dem Zebrastreifen, wo dieses blaue Piktogramm ist quasi,
also wirklich genau so an der Grenze von Bürgersteig zu Hauptgebäude,
also wirklich so, das, wo ein normaler Mensch sagt,
lass uns mal da treffen, weil das findet jeder, also so ein Ort halt.
Und der Kramatorsk 2014 gab es auch schon sowas wie die kleine Schlacht um Kramatorsk.
Also da gab es schon, ich glaube zwei Wochen oder so, ich weiß gar nicht wie
lange das ging, gab es da aber, könnte man eher sagen wie so bewaffnete Straßenschlachten um Kramatorsk.
Also nicht mit Panzern oder so, aber schon, dass halt russische Soldaten oder
Separatisten, je nachdem, wer das jetzt erzählt, da waren.
Und als jetzt die Vollinvasion losging 2022, war auch der Flughafen von Kramatorsk
einer der ersten Anlagen, die bombardiert wurden. Also es war so eine der ersten
Raketen, die kamen direkt darauf.
Also es hat ganz offensichtlich auch für die Russen eine Signifikanz.
Also man halt sagt so wirklich, also nicht nur, dass die Ukrainer sagen,
ja, ja, da machen wir ein bisschen Logistik, sondern die Russen sehen das offensichtlich
genauso, dass sie für Millionen Raketen draufwerfen, wenn es losgeht.
Ja, und das ist halt, ich weiß gar nicht, ich glaube, das waren so 100.000 Leute
oder so was, oder 200.000, die da früher gewohnt haben.
Ich vergesse es immer. Es war halt schon eine kleine Stadt halt einfach.
Und man merkt halt einfach so die Menge an Menschen, die sich da bewegt,
passt in keinem Verhältnis mehr zu der Stadtgröße.
Also so da, man trifft mal einen und es gibt halt so.
Ich glaube so zwei, drei Restaurants oder so, die aufhaben, die von Frühstück,
Mittagessen, Abendessen alles anbieten.
Aber das ist auch wieder lustig, nicht so eine Notration oder so aus dem Eimer
auf den Topf, sondern wir kamen da an und haben so gefragt, was gibt es denn am Frühstück?
Und die sagten, ja, Mögt ihr Schak-Schukka oder wir haben Ex-Benedikt,
wir haben hier Lachstoast. Wir haben auch einfach so englisches Frühstück, dieses mit allem drauf.
Es war auch früher schon so ein Frühstücksrestaurant mit viel Ausball,
aber man sagt, Sagt, okay, ja gut, die Straße ist ja frei, der Kram kommt an.
Das ist so ein bisschen bizarr, weil wir dachten so, es gibt jetzt die Auswahl
Suppe oder Joghurt oder so. Und sie sagt, nö, nö, das ist alles da.
Klar, kannst mit Apple Pay zahlen, das ist ja Ukraine.
Also das ist immer, wo dann so die Realitäten so clashen. Also wir konnten uns
leider nicht duschen, weil es Wasser aus war, aber wir können irgendwie Ex-Benedikt. Genau.
Ex-Benedikt an der Front.
Genau, also das ist halt so, was immer so einfach so komisch ist,
wenn man da ist, so wie diese zwei Welten so interagieren.
Da merkte man einfach, das ist halt wie eine der Frontstädter.
Das war jetzt noch nicht ganz Front, aber so vom Feeling her.
Und ein Hotel, in dem ich da vor Jahren, 2021 war, das ist auch inzwischen bombardiert worden.
Da ist ein Security Advisor von Associate Press auch getötet worden und da gab
es, also man merkt, das ist schon gefährlich da,
aber halt auch mal so, mal so und deswegen haben wir dann auch in einer Privatwohnung
gewohnt bei jemandem, also bei einem Freund vom Freund und da auf der Couch gepennt einfach,
weil das halt dann sicherer ist, als in irgendein Hotel zu gehen und vor allem
in ein Hotel, bei dem bekannt ist, dass Journalisten da sind.
Das ist immer so die schlechteste Wahl inzwischen.
Und deswegen, wir hatten auch Schlafsäcke, Luftmatratzen und so bei und haben
dann halt echt einfach zu fünft in so einer Wohnung halt gepennt.
Das fand ich auch lustig, der kannte uns ja nicht mal.
Wir hatten einen gemeinsamen Bekannten und er sagte, ja, pennt hier ist alles
okay und Kühlschrank ist voll und sagt einfach, wie lange ihr bleiben wollt.
Das ist auch regelmäßig ganz so gewesen, dass das so ganz unkompliziert ist,
dass man da halt einfach dann also mitten im Kriegsgebiet bei irgendwem wohnt.
Und lustig war in dem Fall auch die Einweisung für, was ist,
wenn hier ein sozusagen ein Raketenschlag oder so kommt, wo geht's hin?
Weil der eine sagte, was ist denn, wenn hier Alarm ist? Sagt der,
Alarm ist die ganze Zeit.
Ja, oder wenn Angriff ist, sagt der, ja komm, das ist zehnmal am Tag.
Also sagen wir, wenn Angriff dicht ist, also so man schon merkt,
so die Stufen werden, also in Deutschland macht es die Leute fertig,
wenn sie hören, da gibt es Luftalarme, nee, nee, wenn es da hinten knallt,
dann bleiben wir einfach am Frühstückstisch, weil weißt du, du kannst nicht
jedes Mal aufstehen, wenn Artillerie kommt.
Also sagen wir, wenn die Scheiben wackeln, okay, dann laufen wir alle runter
zur Straße, nicht Aufzug benutzen, sondern laufen.
Und dann bleiben wir da, weil hier gibt es eh keinen Bunker.
Und dann so, okay, dann stehen wir auf der Straße rum.
Ja, weil wenn es das Gebäude trifft, bist du nicht verschüttet.
Das ist dann schon der Vorteil.
Okay, also wenn der Angriff kommt, warten wir einfach auf der Straße und gucken,
wo es runter geht. Das ist natürlich auch ein guter Plan.
Aber du bist ja dann noch näher an die Front gereist.
Genau, dann ging es nach Pokrovsk. Das ist so ein Ort, ich meine,
der hatte mal 50.000, 60.000 Einwohner.
Ein bisschen ironisch ist, vor einem Jahr haben wir immer in Prokofsk im Hotel
gewohnt und sind nach Kramatorsk gefahren, weil das gefährlicher war in Kramatorsk.
Und da merkt man, jetzt hat es sich halt gedreht, Kramatorsk ist nicht sicherer
geworden, aber Prokofsk so unsicher, dass jetzt Kramatorsk die bessere Option ist zum Wohnen.
In Prokofs haben die uns gesagt, so und auch in Prokofs war ich auch in einem
Hotel, was dann bombardiert wurde, im Druschpa.
Also es ist auch so, man hat inzwischen in jedem dieser Orte irgendwie ein Hotel,
wo man mal war und was dann bombardiert wurde.
Das ist auch irgendwie so ein unrühmlicher Rekord, den man dann irgendwann bei den Journalisten hat.
So wie viele Hotels hast du schon bombardiert gehabt? Ah, bei mir sind sieben. Oh, bei dem schon zehn.
Und in Pokrovsk haben sie uns gesagt, also die haben ungefähr 100 bis 150 so
FPW-Drohnen am Tag, die da anfliegen.
Das fand ich schon beeindruckend, weil der Ordnung.
Also russische.
Genau, russische, also so kleine Quadcopter, die billig sind und die irgendwo hinstürzen.
Und im Normalfall mehrmals am Tag entweder eine Rakete, Artillerie,
irgendwie so verschiedener Kram.
Und Pokrovsk ist halt so ein, eigentlich die Stadt selbst ist nicht wichtig,
es ist so ein Landstraßenknotenpunkt, könnte man sagen.
Also die so mehrere lasterbefahrbare Straßen treffen sich da und gehen dann
so nach Norden, Süden, Osten, Westen weg.
Also deswegen hat das eine gewisse Relevanz.
Und es ist ein ganz wichtiger Eisenbahnknotenpunkt.
Also ja, das auch. Also so insgesamt Logistik. Also geht da einfach rein und raus.
Also der Ort selber ist quasi belanglos, aber er ist halt da,
wo sich eine Menge Routen kreuzen und der Bahnhof ist ganz schön groß.
So ein Hannover.
Ja genau. Im Kleinen.
Genau sowas.
Niemand will nach Hannover, aber man muss halt immer da durchfahren.
Ich darf das ja sagen.
Ich bin da auf durchgefahren, ich kann das auch sagen.
Ja und wir waren auch an dem Bahnhof, das war mir auch nicht klar,
also es sind halt zig Gütergleise, also einfach so ein Zug lang glaube ich das
Gleis und dann ganz viele nebeneinander, dass man halt so Waggons sortieren
kann und Züge irgendwie zwischenparken kann und sowas.
Überraschend groß für die Größe der Stadt. Aber auch alles merkt man so,
mir scheint so seit Sowjetzeit nur noch gewartet immer, aber es ist halt nicht
eine moderne Anlage oder so, sondern man sieht halt, das Zeug ist echt alt alles.
Also und so am Leben gehalten, aber nicht auf den Stand der Technik gebracht oder so.
Und da ist noch weniger los als in Krammerthorst.
Also es ist so, man kommt so in eine Gegend und sagt, oh, hier ist nicht viel
los. Und dann merkt man, nee, da ist noch weniger und da ist noch weniger.
Also es gibt immer so Abstufungen.
Und in Puckhoffs haben wir dann auch gesehen, auch die sozusagen die Lebensumstände.
Also wir waren ja mit ein paar Leuten in einer Wohnung mit, da muss man schon
sagen, in einer Wohnung mit Tür.
Da habe ich gelernt, da gibt es Unterschiede. In Puckhoffs gab es dann auch
die Wohnung ohne Tür, weil die schon rausgeflogen war.
Und keine Scheiben mehr, sondern so Holzbretter davor,
oder auch so Sachen wie, dass die Duschen so oft nicht gingen,
dass die quasi aus Holzlatten und Planen wie so Duschen im Freien gebaut haben
mit einem riesen Kanister quasi drauf,
also mit so, ich weiß nicht, ich schätze mal 100 Liter oder sowas,
so einem schwarzen Kanister drauf und dann wird der in der Sonne auch noch ein
bisschen warm, dann hat man so lauwarmes Wasser,
aber es sieht dann echt aus wie in so einem zusammengezimmerten Flüchtlingscamp
oder sowas schon, aber da merkt man, da geht es dann immer so noch eine Stufe
runter, was Infrastruktur angeht.
Da gibt es dann auch keine Restaurants mehr. Aber es gab so,
ja, so was man hier halt als Kiosk oder Späti bezeichnen würde, sowas in der Art.
Es gab so kleine Shops, wo man halt aber alles Grundlegende trotzdem bekommt
und halt auch natürlich immer, man zahlt nur mit Karte.
So, das finde ich auch so geil. Das ist die letzte Ecke, wo du noch irgendwie
eine Cola kriegst, aber ja, Apple Pay geht, das ist kein Ding.
Und da waren wir bei der Feuerwehr, die halt dauernd da irgendwas löschen muss,
wenn irgendwo eine Rakete runterkam oder irgendwas.
Und das war ganz spannend, weil ich habe mit dem Leiter der Wache oder wie sich
das genau nennt gesprochen,
der war ganz schön jung, der war so Anfang 20 und der sagte,
er war in der Ausbildung zum Feuerwehrmann, als die Invasion losging in so einer
Klasse halt oder in so einer Gruppe.
Hat dann auch gesagt, okay, dann jetzt sofort los, wir müssen irgendwie helfen.
Und die Ausbilder haben gesagt, nee, nee, nee, ihr geht überhaupt nirgends hin.
Weil die haben gesagt, wenn der Krieg jetzt losgeht, meinst du, der ist morgen vorbei?
Nee, also müsst ihr gut ausgebildet sein und gut qualifiziert sein und dann geht ihr hin.
Weil es bringt uns nichts, wenn jetzt alle irgendwie wie die aufgescheuchten Hühner rumrennen.
Und dann hieß es bei einigen von denen, wie bei ihm, ihr macht auch nicht nur Feuerwehrmann,
sondern ihr macht noch so ein paar Zusatzqualifikationen und halt auch sowas
wie Wache leiten und so wie so ein ganz grundlegender Kurs, explodierende Sachen
und nochmal so extra Gefahrstoffe, also so wirklich was ist,
wenn der Panzer brennt, also wo brennt er gefährlich und so.
Und dadurch hat er bis Mitte 2023 seine Ausbildung noch gemacht.
Und er saß jeden Tag, dann hat er gesagt, Leute, ich will raus hier.
Hat gesagt, ja, aber rückblickend war das schon genau richtig,
wie die es gemacht haben.
Weil er halt wirklich gut ausgebildet, dann in die Praxis kam und dann in anderen
Wachen wie so den praktischen Teil gelernt hat.
Und sagt so, jetzt fühlt er sich aber wirklich fit, selbst für diesen Job in
Pokrovsk. weil er halt, wenn was passiert, dann weiß er, was er zu tun hat und
rennt halt nicht rum und sagt, ah, lass mal gucken, wie wir löschen,
sondern sagt, ah, der Gefahrstoff, das Mittel, so geht das.
Fand ich auch ganz spannend und ich hatte dann auch gefragt,
weil mir schien, er war einer der Jüngsten in der Wache, also viele so erfahrene
Feuerwehrleute und habe gefragt, ist das irgendwie eine Schwierigkeit?
Und da sagt er auch, irgendwie in der Ukraine oft gar nicht,
weil das da häufiger so ist, dass junge Leute auch Firmen gründen und ältere
Entwickler einstellen oder irgendwas in der Art, also sagt,
das ist da nicht so kompliziert mit, ich bin aber älter und ich bin jünger oder
so, sondern es muss halt laufen und die hatten auch,
also als wir dann in der Wache waren, die haben gesagt, wir können Fotos machen,
filmen und so, nur nicht die Wache von außen und nie so filmen,
dass man rausgucken kann, also dass die nicht lokalisiert werden kann,
weil es halt offensichtlich nicht mehr im Standort war wie früher, sondern woanders.
Und wir hatten uns auch erst gewundert, weil der Feuerwehrwagen nicht,
also der große Wagen von denen nicht einfach rausfahren konnte,
sondern wie so ein, wenn in drei Zügen machen mussten, dachten wir,
wie bescheuert ist denn das?
Er sagt, achso, okay, weil die in irgendeiner anderen Liegenschaft sozusagen
sind und dann mussten sie halt mit dem klarkommen, was es gibt.
Und einer stand die ganze Zeit draußen, erst dachte ich, der raucht da oder
so und das war aber ein Spotter,
der die ganze Zeit mit Weste, Helm und so einem geschützten Kragen rumstand
und ohne Fernglas oder so, sondern einfach nur in der Gegend rumgeguckt hat.
Die haben auch gesagt, das sieht immer so blöd aus, ist aber halt auch eine
sehr schwierige Aufgabe, weil du musst so ein Gespür für haben,
höre ich jetzt diese kleinen FPV-Drohnen, den Propeller oder nicht.
Sag klar, wenn die Dinger nah sind, hörst du es. Aber es geht ja darum,
möglichst früh zu sagen, ich glaube, da kommt was.
Oder auch so Sachen wie Rakete oder Artillerie. Oder auch, es hat dann einmal
direkt, als wir da waren, richtig heftig geknallt und es hat gar keiner sich
da auch nur einen Millimeter bewegt. Das hat die überhaupt nicht interessiert.
Und dann dachte ich, irgendeine Reaktion muss doch kommen. Und sie sagt,
das war doch outgoing. Also es sind doch unsere, die schießen.
Ich sagte, okay, ich höre den Unterschied nicht, aber es war denen so völlig klar.
Ja, weil es ein interessanter Profil hat natürlich.
Ja genau und wo ich dachte, das wurde mir zwar immer wieder erklärt,
aber für mich ist das nicht sofort erkennbar.
Also es ist halt ein Knall, also sozusagen wenn es reingeht,
knallt es und dann hört man Splitter fliegen und so weiter. Aber es ist trotzdem
so, für mich ist es erstmal ein echt lauter Knall, der echt nah war und da merkt
man, es war denen so klar, dass nichts ist, das hat die überhaupt nicht interessiert.
Und dann genau der Typ, der draußen steht, kann das halt noch für viel mehr Sachen ordentlich.
Deswegen steht der draußen.
Vielleicht sollte man nochmal kurz erläutern, in welcher Situation Prokofs gerade
ist, weil das ist ja ungefähr 50 Kilometer von der Großstadt Donetsk,
die ja schon seit langem von den Russen besetzt ist.
Und bis vor einigen Monaten lag die Frontlinie auch noch gut 40 Kilometer entfernt,
unmittelbar vor der Stadt Donetsk.
Das war eigentlich die ganze Zeit eine festgefahrene Linie, die von den Ukrainern
gut verteidigt worden ist. bis eben auf DIVKA viel mehr.
Vor allem, nicht nur, aber im Wesentlichen durch die ausbleibende Unterstützung
von Artillerie-Munitionen durch den Westen und deswegen mussten halt die Ukrainer
nicht nur Avtivka aufgeben,
sondern haben dann in der Folge auch ein relativ großes Gebiet,
das größte Gebiet, was die Russen überhaupt eingenommen haben,
mussten sie dann irgendwie abgeben sozusagen.
Und da sind sie jetzt bis auf 10 Kilometer auf Prokofsk rangekommen.
Die Rösten haben da ungefähr so 800 Quadratkilometer.
Ein Berlin. Ja, sowas in der Größenordnung genommen und stehen jetzt quasi unmittelbar
vor Prokofs und ja auch in absoluter Artilleriereichweite,
definitiv, sodass man davon ausgehen kann,
dass hier die Bedrohung sehr groß ist.
Ob es den Russen jetzt noch gelingen wird, hier in diesem Jahr Prokofs einzunehmen,
da gibt es sehr unterschiedliche Berichte darüber.
Einerseits scheinen sich die Russen in diesem Gebiet auch extrem übernommen zu haben,
also die Verluste um Avtivka waren ja schon extrem hoch und auch der Vorstoß,
der derzeit gemacht wird, wird ja von den Ukrainern immer so betrieben mit unser
größtes Gut sind unsere Leute.
Wir ziehen uns im Zweifelsfall früher zurück und sorgen dafür,
dass die Russen in ihrem...
In ihrer Angriffsbewegung entsprechend hohe Verluste haben. Man sagt ja immer,
was weiß ich, 1 zu 5, 1 zu 6, was auch immer.
Du musst sehr viel mehr Ressourcen verbrennen, um einen entsprechenden Angriffserfolg zu haben.
Das heißt, in dieser Verteidigungsbewegung sind die Ukrainer in der Lage,
den Russen großen Schaden zu machen.
Aber auf der anderen Seite ist halt das Ressourcenverhältnis zwischen Ukraine
und Russland immer noch auch in diesem Bereich, so dass es kontinuierlich den
Russen gelingt, derzeit kleine,
aber eben signifikante Schritte zu machen, die dann im zunehmenden Maße bestimmte
Stellungen bedrohen und eine dieser bedrohten Städte ist halt jetzt Prokrovsk.
10 Kilometer sind es noch.
In den letzten Tagen gab es weitere Vorstöße jetzt nicht unmittelbar vor der Stadt.
Man muss dazu sagen, dass die Ukrainer das natürlich jetzt auch genutzt haben,
um die Stellung dort massiv auszubauen und wir stehen halt jetzt vor dem Matschherbst,
der wahrscheinlich ohnehin Vorstöße zumindest jenseits der Straßen schwierig
bis unmöglich machen wird. Wie war das Wetter also damals?
22 Grad und strahlender Sonnenschein. Aber alle warteten quasi darauf,
dass es jetzt langsam mal kippen und in Regen übergehen muss.
Also war so wahrscheinlich einer der letzten hübschen Tage durch Zufall.
Gab dann aber das andere Problem.
In Pokrovsk sind viele Straßen gar nicht asphaltiert. Und wenn es trocken ist,
hast du halt irren Staub in der Luft.
Also das war mir auch nicht klar, so wie simpel das da zum Teil ist.
Weil eigentlich immer, wenn ich im Donbass war, waren wir zumindest noch auf
asphaltierten Straßen unterwegs.
Und die großen sind es schon auch so. Und wenn man dann aber durch den Ort fuhrt,
War eine Menge nicht asphaltiert. Und die Feuerwehr sagte, sie hatten dann auch
einige Probleme immer wieder.
Also zum einen, sie fahren halt nicht mit Blaulicht und Sirene,
weil man will ja nicht auffallen und sagen, riesiger roter Wagen ist schlecht
genug für sie zurzeit schon.
Aber dann so diese Straßen mit irren Schlaglöchern und sowas.
Viel Staub.
Ja genau, viel Staub. Also man sieht, wo die Autos langfahren.
Wenn man jetzt so eine FPV-Drohne fliegt, ist das ein bisschen blöd.
Also weil die Russen sehen halt, da hinten ist eine Staubwolke,
da fährt was oder wahrscheinlich was.
Und auch einfach so ganz schlichtweg im Straßenverkehr, dass man gar nicht so
weit gucken konnte oft. Also so eine Menge so Kleinkramprobleme,
die jetzt gar nicht so richtig mit dem Krieg zu tun haben, die aber trotzdem
Probleme dann mit dem Alltag machen.
Gerade wenn man eigentlich lieber schnell fahren will und nicht auf so schlechten Straßen.
Aber ja, dann kann sich ja vorstellen, wenn die Straßen dann nass werden,
dann hast du halt diese riesen Matschpartys und dann brauchst du halt die Geländewagen,
die du da überall siehst, um überhaupt auch nur durch die Stadt sinnvoll zu kommen.
Bist du nicht dann, wenn du von Kramatorsk gekommen bist, bist du dann über
Konstantinivka gefahren oder oben rum gefahren?
Genau, oben rum, weil das ist ein bisschen heiß.
Ja, vor allem ist glaube ich auch diese Brücke an der einen Stelle zerschossen
worden, die diese Nachbarstadt mit Prokofs verbindet.
Ja genau, es gibt eine Möglichkeit rüber zu fahren, aber die Brücke ist platt.
Wie so oft, man muss dann so, sieht echt aus wie so selbstgebaute Holzbrücken zum Teil.
So wie wenn ein guter Handwerker, aber mit dem was gerade da war eine Brücke
zusammengeschustert hat. Das ist echt abenteuerlich teilweise.
Ja, okay, gut. Was machst du da für eine Stimmung aus?
Also hast du da auch jenseits der Feuerwehr Kontakte mit den militärischen Gruppen?
Genau, also wir haben sowohl mit Freiwilligen aus dem Ausland,
Freiwilligen aus der Ukraine und halt mit Leuten in dem Shop einfach gesprochen,
die da so ihren Kram verkaufen.
Das Komische ist, es ist so ein Hin und Her.
Wenn man so normal mit denen spricht, die machen eine Menge blöder Witze und
so immer, um die Stimmung halt oben zu halten.
Also einfach auch, als nix los war, die haben so 90er Jahre Pop laufen lassen
und Karaoke gesungen und so ein Kram.
Also einfach so alles, was die Stimmung hebt und wo du irgendwie gerade Bock drauf hast einfach.
Und auf der anderen Seite, wenn man da mit ihnen gesprochen hat,
auch über Verluste und so, sagen sie, ja, die sind schon üppig.
Das ist ein sehr weites Spektrum.
Quantifizier mal, ja.
Nö, über Zahlen spricht so keiner. Also das war aber sozusagen von Lviv bis Pokrovsk bei allen.
Also viele haben gesagt, ja, ist nicht so gut zur Zeit, aber niemand will auch
nur eine Prozentzahl, eine Menge. Also man merkt so, niemand will es genauer
sagen, aber offensichtlich ist es nicht gut.
Und die Operational Security ist sozusagen mittlerweile eingebrannt in die Bevölkerung wahrscheinlich.
Absolut. Und man merkt es halt, also gerade wenn man vor Ort ist,
reden die über eine Menge Sachen offener, weil sie halt von ausgehen,
wenn du so weit nach vorne kommst, dann ist dir schon klar, worüber du redest und worüber nicht.
Oder auch, wenn die sagen, hey, willst du mal was echt Cooles sehen,
aber nicht weitererzählen, dass das hier steht oder sowas.
Also man merkt, man kriegt eine Menge Vertrauen so von den Leuten auch,
weil sie aber von ausgehen, wenn wir da sind und es ist klar,
wenn wir, also so der alte Spruch aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg,
loose lips sink ships, also so eine unbedachte Bemerkung und das Schiff geht unter.
Ähm, und das, also das ist immer so
ein bisschen so eine ganz interessante Mischung auch, wo man merkt, die,
ich habe nicht das Gefühl, dass die sich verstellen, vor allem wenn man ein
paar Tage mit denen da rumhängt und die so offener und entspannter werden,
aber es ist halt so ein bisschen wie so Untergangsstimmung, wo du sagst,
okay, und dann lass uns nochmal alle gute Laune rausholen, die wir haben,
weil du weißt nicht, wer morgen noch da ist.
Also so echt merkwürdig, weil so wenn man über die schwierigen Sachen redet,
merkt man, die sind echt bedrückt und die haben eine Menge Leute verloren, die sie kennen.
Also Freunde, Verwandte, andere Soldaten, Rettungskräfte und so.
Aber sie haben halt keinen Bock so deprimiert rumzusitzen und machen deswegen immer,
alles an guter Laune oder die haben auch jede Menge Witze über uns gemacht und
übereinander aber so wie wenn man so ausgelassene Partystimmung oder so hat
und alle gut drauf sind und das aber ganz viel und,
Das denke ich immer, es kommt ja meist raus, wenn es wirklich nicht gut läuft.
Also so und entweder sitzt du dann halt echt heulend in der Ecke oder du gehst
auf sowas über und sagst komm und jetzt nochmal hier richtig Stimmung.
Haben sich die Leute darüber gewundert, dass ihr da seid?
Also wie wird man sozusagen empfangen als offensichtlich nicht Ukrainer,
nicht unmittelbar Betroffene?
Das sind so zwei Phasen sozusagen, wenn man sich dem Gebiet nähert gibt es unglaublich
viele so Checkpoints von Militär und Geheimdienst,
die halt sagen, was treibst du hier und dann habe ich halt diese Militärakreditierung
und sage, grundsätzlich darf ich hier, dann sagen die ja schön und gut,
aber was machst du hier, wer bist du und so erzähl mal, also dann sozusagen
je dichter man kommt, desto,
quasi genauer wird geguckt ist auch so, wenn man sozusagen also je.
Dichter man der Front.
Weil wenn man so durch Rake fährt und durch so so ein Checkpoint kommt,
dann sagen die oft, ah, Deutscher, steht Presse auf dem Auto, ja, ja, verweiter.
Und dann ein Stück weiter sagen die, hast du eine Presseakkreditierung hier? Ja, okay, verweiter.
Und dann merkt man aber, wie das so, dann ist es so, wir brauchen ein Foto von
dir mit der Akkreditierung und deinem Kennzeichen vor deinem Auto.
Also so, keine Ahnung, wo das hingeht, aber wo man wohl dann nachher guckt,
ist es wirklich der mit dem Auto und der Akkreditierung oder vielleicht machen
die Stichproben oder ich weiß es nicht.
Aber wo man einfach merkt, das wird so mehr Und dann, wenn man in dem Bereich
ist, so an der Front, wo es keine Checkpoints mehr gibt, weil das so das Frontgebiet
ist, dann gehen alle von aus, wenn du da bist, gehörst du da schon hin.
Also erstmal, man merkt, die Offenheit ist, also sie sind ziemlich offen.
Zumindest, oder auch, dann sagt man, pass auf, ich würde jetzt mal irgendwie
dir ein paar Fragen vor der Kamera stellen und dann merkt man,
okay, dann ist es natürlich so ein bisschen verschlossener oder höflicher oder
so, wie soll man sagen, diplomatischer oft formuliert.
Aber ansonsten hat man das Gefühl, dass sie schon ganz normal mit einem so offen umgehen.
Und die Stimmung ist halt so sozusagen persönlich gut und was den Krieg angeht, sagen die alle,
mal sehen, wie lange das hier gut geht mit der Stadt und so.
Weil sie halt alle sagen, sie haben Leute, die gut sind, sie haben Leute, die
engagiert sind, sie haben Leute, die da sein wollen, aber sie haben einfach
nicht genug Munition, also weder fürs Gewehr noch für den Panzer noch für,
also so die meinen so ganz grob, sie haben ungefähr 10% von dem,
was sie gerne hätten, damit sie wirklich so voll,
draufgehen können die ganze Zeit und vielleicht 20% von dem,
was sie bräuchten, also so irgendwo in dem Rahmen ist, was so ihr was ihnen fehlt sozusagen.
Krass.
Wenn man sich jetzt der Frontlinie nähert, was würdest du sagen,
also wie dick ist dieser Speckgürtel sozusagen um diese Front herum,
wo das eigentliche gesellschaftliche Leben signifikant eingeschränkt ist,
wo man das Gefühl hat, man ist jetzt schon an der Front, auch wenn man jetzt
nicht direkt an der Front ist.
Ich würde echt sagen, so ziemlich genau so Artillerie-Reichweite kommt mir immer so vor.
Also so 30, 40 Kilometer ist so der Bereich,
wo so wie Anarchie herrscht und wo man echt merkt, also auch so triviale Sachen
wie in Rakiv und so in den Städten, wenn man da zu schnell fährt,
da gibt es Radarfallen, die Polizei lasert ein und alles mögliche.
Und wenn man sozusagen über diese Grenze, so diese letzten Checkpoints in diese
30, 50 Kilometer vor der Front kommt, dann ändert sich das und alle fahren eigentlich
nur Vollgas oder stehen irgendwo, wo sie von oben nicht zu sehen sind.
Also dann weiß man immer so, okay, jetzt sind wir in dem Bereich, wo es wild wird.
Und mir scheint dann immer, das normale Leben hat man, wenn man so 30 Kilometer
von der Front weggeht und dann in die nächste Stadt, Also in die nächste Kleinstadt
oder so, da ist dann meist wieder ein relativ normales Leben.
Also fehlt dann auch ein Drittel der Bevölkerung oder so, aber da sind dann
Restaurants auf, da sind irgendwie Kinos zum Teil auf und so.
Also das geht relativ schnell. Also mir scheint ja wirklich nicht in dem Sinne
Angst vor dem Krieg, wie der da rüberkommt, sondern einfach nur ganz akut vor
keine Artillerie und keine FPV-Drohnen.
Und sobald man aus der Reichweite raus ist, ist das wieder ziemlich gut sofort.
Also das ist halt auch so krass, weil das ist dann so eine Stunde mit dem Auto oder so manchmal,
je nachdem wie die Landstraße so läuft, aber zwischen diesem,
wo man echt ein schlechtes Gefühl den ganzen Tag lang hat und einer Gegend,
die ein ziemlich normales Stadtleben so bietet.
Ja, es ist eh sehr schwer vorzustellen, wenn man aus diesen Gebieten ist,
was einen dann sozusagen noch da hält.
Weil offensichtlich sind ja nicht alle,
die dort sind, jetzt aktiv an der Verteidigung des Landes beteiligt,
sondern vielleicht sekundär, weil sie natürlich die Leute vor Ort unterstützen,
aber manche sind vielleicht auch dazu nicht in der Lage, ältere Leute,
die in irgendeiner Form noch versuchen, irgendeiner Normalität zu folgen,
ohne aber den Beschluss gefasst zu haben, das woanders zu tun.
Ja, also relativ häufig tatsächlich, also wenn man Kinder oder Jugendliche sieht,
weil die Eltern Polizei oder Rettungsdienst sind, weil das war meine Hauptfrage
immer, warum sind da noch Kinder?
Also bei Erwachsenen gibt es verschiedene Gründe, aber so Schulkinder vom Alter
her teilweise und oft tatsächlich, weil die Eltern sozusagen zivile Schutzaufgaben
übernehmen. Die Soldaten sagen immer, nee, mein Kind kommt hier nicht in die Nähe.
Aber die Soldaten bewegen sich ja. Und die Leute, die sozusagen,
weiß jemand, eine Frau, die seit 50 Jahren oder so Krankenschwester da war und
dann ihr Kind und das Enkelkind oder so sind dann auch noch da.
So was hatte ich immer wieder erlebt und auch gedacht. dachte,
okay, ich weiß nicht, ich würde ja zumindest einen Ort weiter.
Aber das war tatsächlich so der häufigste Fall.
Und eben wie du sagst, einfach alte Leute, die sagen, ich habe hier irgendwie
die Nazis erlebt und Stalin und dann irgendwie Sowjetunion und jetzt ist halt,
weißt du, ist wieder irgendwas.
So, dafür bewege ich mich nicht mehr.
Und wenn ich sterbe, dann sterbe ich hier.
Dann zu Hause, genau. So das Übliche, ja.
Ja, weil es gibt ja andere Städte, die noch sehr viel stärker unter so einer
Bedrohung ist, allen voran Kherson im Süden,
wo ja quasi die Russen auf der anderen Seite des Flusses sind und die Stadt
liegt am Fluss und dort ist derzeit die Situation,
dass da einfach die Russen zynisch ausgedrückt den ganzen Tag Computerspiele spielen.
Also die fliegen einfach mit ihren Drohnen durch die Stadt und lassen überall
Bomben auf Leute fallen.
Das ist also der absolute Top-Terror. In der Hinsicht glaube ich ist es gerade
nirgendwo so schlimm wie dort in Kherson.
Aber im Prinzip gilt das ja auch für all diese ganzen Orte, weil ob es jetzt
irgendwie eine Granate von einer Drohne ist oder Artillerie,
hast du ja letzten Endes auch nicht die Wahl.
So, aber du bist ja nicht in Prokofsk geblieben, sondern nochmal näher rangezogen.
Ja, so je nachdem. Ich bin mir immer nicht sicher.
Ich sehe ja auch diese Karten auf irgendwie Live-UA-Map und so.
Da habe ich gemerkt, die reine Distanz zum nächsten Russen ist gar nicht mal
das Entscheidende, sondern es ist halt mal besser, mal schlechter,
je nachdem, wo mehr geschossen wird.
Nach ein paar Tagen bin ich dann zurück und eigentlich war mein Plan von Kamatorsk
wieder die M3 nach Charkiv und dann so zurückzufahren.
Aber irgendwas war auf der M3 gesperrt oder ein Unfall.
Was tatsächlich immer wieder passiert ist, wenn die mit diesen großen Tiefladern
fahren, dass die irgendwie, was weiß ich, in irgendeiner Form verunglücken und
dann ist halt direkt so eine Landstraße dicht.
Habe ich nie gesehen. Ich dachte, wenn so ein Panzer runterrutscht vom Schlepper
oder so, keine Ahnung. Also wahrscheinlich hast du da ein paar Stunden zu tun.
Und dann bin ich so im Bogen gefahren.
Also ich habe gedacht, also mein Navi hat gesagt, hey, da ist irgendwie zu und
man sagt, das Stau ist, fahr doch mal hier rum.
Und ich habe gedacht, ja, so der Roboter hat meistens recht, folge ich dem mal.
Und bin dann halt abgebogen von der M3 und bin erst nach Liman in die Richtung
oder Lümern, wie man es ausspricht und dann weiter nach Norden da lang und dann zurück in Isium rein.
Und das war dann das, was wir sozusagen wie anfangs die Fragen waren, was ist da alles kaputt?
Und so in diesem Bogen, den ich da gefahren bin, also so nochmal weiter nach Osten, also so,
Eigentlich ja auch so 30, 30, 40 Kilometer von der Front, während Pokrovsk ja
theoretisch viel dichter dran war.
Aber man merkte halt, dass diese Gegend, so Liman bis Isium da oben,
dass das länger offensichtlich unter Beschuss war.
Also so, weil da einfach so viel kaputt war.
Also ich sehe gerade 20 Kilometer zum Teil. Aber halt da gab es dann wirklich
so Dörfer, durch die man fährt.
Also es gibt manchmal so Dörfer, da ist die Landstraße in der Mitte und rechts
und links sind so zwei, drei Reihen Häuser. Die sind nicht groß,
vielleicht ein paar Dutzend Häuser, wenn es hochkommt.
Aber alles, was ich sehen konnte, war halt einfach nur kaputt.
Also so alles in Sichtweite kaputt. Also im Sinne von teilweise ein Krater,
teilweise das Dachwerk, teilweise Haus eingestürzt.
Also so alle Varianten. Aber man merkte so 90 Prozent kaputt von dem,
was man gesehen hat, weil da halt seit zwei Jahren was runterkommt.
Ja und Lühmann war ja auch stark umkämpft bei der Rückeroberung dieses von Rakiv.
Das war dann der letzte große Ort, den die Ukrainer zurückgewinnen konnten.
Auch sehr wichtig, weil Liman auch ein ganz wichtiger Eisenbahnknotenpunkt ist.
Dahinter ging es dann irgendwann nicht weiter. Da kommt ja dieses riesige Waldgebiet
nördlich vom Siverodonetsk-Fluss und Kremina ist dann sozusagen schon die nächste
große russische Stellung,
die war sehr umkämpft in den letzten zwei Jahren, aber viel ist dort nicht geschehen.
Und dann eben ist dort eben die schon erwähnte Front an dem Ost-Kiel-Fluss sozusagen
entstanden und genau an dessen Südende bist du dann irgendwie vorbeigekommen.
Genau, also ich glaube ich war so auf der ersten brauchbaren Landstraße oder
größeren Landstraße zur Front, aber da sind wie gesagt 20, 30 Kilometer zwischen,
da kommen so Felder und so kleine Straßen noch.
Dann, also in der Gegend fährt man dann im Normalfall mit allen Fenstern im
Auto immer auf, falls irgendwas explodiert, dass man weniger Splitter abkriegt einfach.
Und das ist auch immer so ein Punkt, ich will ja nicht zu unvorsichtig sein,
also auch wenn das von außen vielleicht anders aussieht, aber auf der anderen
Seite will ich auch nicht zu paranoid sein, so wo ist die Balance?
Und dann sagt man, nur weil man in so einer Gegend fährt, zieht man sich jetzt
nicht schussig Reveste und Helm immer an, weil das Zeug ist auch unbequem und
irgendwann wird man bescheuert, wenn man immer so in dieser Angst sich selber hält.
Also hatte ich das zwar alles griffbereit, aber nicht an.
Und dann hörte ich so auf einmal richtig lautes Knallen, also man so merkt,
ja, also so, dass man schon Druckwelle merkt.
Also entweder sehr groß oder es ist sehr dicht, also eins von beiden.
Aber auf jeden Fall laut, so quasi aus dem Gebüsch nebenan, also aus diesem
Wald, also es ist halt so eine Landstraße und richtig große Waldgebiete drumherum.
Ich habe gesagt, okay, jetzt wieder die Frage, geht das rein oder raus?
Und da dachte ich, na gut, ich vermute, das ist rausgehende Artillerie und die
haben es halt im Wald versteckt. Das würde Sinn ergeben.
Die wird aber dann auch oft beantwortet.
Ja genau, das war der Punkt. Da habe ich gedacht, okay, soll ich jetzt anhalten
und mir Weston und Hellmann ziehen?
Aber dachte, wenn ich jetzt direkt neben irgendeiner Artillerie anhalte,
dann kommen die doch raus und sagen, was machst du hier? Erst mal ein Stück weiterfahren.
Und dann kamen so zwei Sachen, die so kurz hintereinander waren.
Also es war so, manchmal denkt man nicht richtig nach.
Also es hat da ein paar Mal echt gerumst und dann hat sich sowas auf der,
was man so im Augenwinkel sieht, so auf der Straße bewegt.
Also da rennen manchmal Hunde rum, Katzen, irgendwelche Viecher.
Dann wollte ich anhalten.
Tagsüber war das?
Ja, tagsüber, genau. Und dann wollte ich anhalten und da war auch wie so ein
Späti oder so ein kleiner Shop und dachte, gut, noch eben was zu trinken holen
und dann, wenn ich wieder einsteige, Weston und Helmann ziehen.
Hab angehalten und dann brüllten die so sinngemäß, hau ab, hau ab.
Ich hab gesagt, ja, keine Ahnung, wir hätten den ersten unhöflichen Ukrainer
getroffen, was willst du?
Und dann ein bisschen spät geschaltet, dann zeigten die halt auf diese,
wo ich halt nicht so richtig drauf geachtet habe, das was ich so bewegt habe,
dachte ich, ja okay, hier liegen Ziegelsteine.
Und so, wenn man so schön sagt, so der Groschen fällt pfennigweise,
wenn so Ziegelsteine sich auf die Straße schieben, also dann ja selten,
weil sie irgendwie einen Ausflug machen.
Er sagt, Moment, es hat geknallt und dann kamen Ziegelsteine auf die Straße
geflogen. Was ist gerade passiert?
Okay, und dann haben sie halt offensichtlich dahinter irgendwo ein Haus getroffen.
Und die Steine, ich muss halt echt so am Ende von der Reichweite des Steinflugs
oder so gewesen sein. Also es hat zum Glück nichts das Fahrzeug getroffen.
Aber so, dass so ein paar Dinge halt auf der Straße ankamen.
Und dann fügte sich auch ein, warum die Ukrainer so unhöflich waren,
als ich da was zu trinken kaufen wollte. dass sie sagten, na ab hier, sofort weiter.
Sagt, ah, jetzt fügt sich das Bild zusammen.
Weil du als Ziel angesehen werden konntest.
Erstmal mit dem blöden Auto sofort weg hier und zum anderen bist du blöd, was du hier rumfährst.
Und dann halt Weston und Helm ganz schnell angezogen und dann wirklich sehr,
sehr schnell bis Isium gefahren.
Und da war auch nicht viel anderer Verkehr. Das ist gut und schlecht,
weil wenn da sonst niemand ist, kann man schnell fahren. Aber man weiß auch
nicht genau, wo zum Beispiel ein Schlagloch ist, was jeder im Dorf kennt oder so.
Manchmal gibt es da Riesenschlaglöcher, so Meter Durchmesser,
40 Zentimeter tief oder sowas.
Und es gab ein, zwei Stellen, an denen die Landstraße wie so 90 Grad um die
Ecke ging, also wo man ein bisschen aufpassen musste.
Und das Problem ist halt, im Normalfall würde man ja in so Gegenden auch gar
nicht unbedingt hinkommen, weil die Ukrainer sagen, nee, nee,
so, wenn du hier als Tourist unterwegs bist, dann lass das mal schön.
Aber klar, wenn man mit der Akkreditierung kommt und sozusagen aus dem gefährlicheren
Gebiet einfährt, dann sagen die, ja klar, du weißt ja, was los ist,
du willst schon wissen, was du hier tust.
Und dann spricht auch keiner groß mit einem, weil die denken,
man weiß schon, was Sache ist. Ja, das war ein bisschen wild.
Ähm, warst du denn jetzt in so einem kleinen Dorf relativ nah dran,
eins dieser unzähligen Oleksandrivkas, da gibt es ja irgendwie eine Million
von, genau wie Bilo Horevka, das ist so das Neustadt und der Ukraine.
Stand da noch irgendwas, also war da alles im Eimer oder?
Also fast alles im Eimer. Oder sagen wir mal verlassen vor allem.
Ganz viel zerbombt. Also auch zum Teil Straße kaputt. Auch so Sachen wie das
einfach Bäume umgeknickt im Wald lagen.
Also man denkt, dass der Baum umknickt, da muss ja schon eine Menge Energie wirken.
Also wo man gesehen hat, dass überall irgendwas mal runtergekommen und halt
viel auch die ganzen Städte kaputt.
Aber weil es halt ab und zu diese Kioske gab oder diese kleinen Läden,
die müssen da ja auch irgendwo wohnen.
Also du fährst ja nicht zehn Kilometer weiter, um da deinen zehn Quadratmeter Kiosk aufzumachen.
Also mir scheint, das sind genauso Leute, die dann halt da geblieben sind und
die dann in irgendeinem von den Häusern da noch im Keller wohnen.
Aber das sind genauso Fälle, wo ich mir denke, was treibt ihr hier?
Also zum Beispiel da Isium, was zumindest ein ganzes Stück sicherer ist,
ist, weiß ich nicht, eine halbe Stunde oder sowas vielleicht mit dem Auto oder noch weniger weiter.
Ist für mich immer schwierig nachzuvollziehen, was einen da hält dann.
Also die Dörfer sind eh schon klein, selbst wenn sie intakt sind.
Aber das war, also ich glaube, so wie man sich so dem Klischee nach so einem
Kriegsgebiet vorstellt.
Also halt alles kaputt und keiner, der rumläuft und auch keine Autos,
niemand, der mit dem Hund Gassi geht oder nichts von dem, was so ein normales Bild ausmacht.
Ja, was ist jetzt so dein Gesamteindruck von der Situation und wie blickt denn
die Ukraine derzeit auf den westlichen Support?
Ja, mir scheint so hin und her, sie sagen zum einen, gut, dass was kommt,
aber halt auch schlecht, dass nicht mehr kommt. Also so...
Ja genau, sie sagen mal, sie fühlen sich wie ein Bettler, dem man immer so viel
zu essen gibt, dass er halt über die Runden kommt.
Und ja, also alle, wenn ich die Leute an der Front spreche, erzähle mir das auch genau so.
Sie können so gerade eben unter Verlusten ihre Position halten oder ihren Auftrag
erfüllen, je nachdem, ob das jetzt ein bisschen weitergehen oder dableiben ist.
Aber halt wirklich so das Minimum.
Und sie sehen halt umgekehrt, was alles bei uns rumsteht, was nicht genutzt wird.
Und sagen, das ist doch bizarr. Es wird immer zurückgehalten für den Fall,
dass man doch in einen Krieg verwickelt wird.
Was soll denn passieren? Die Amis werden euch schon nicht von hinten angreifen.
Also, wenn ihr ein Problem habt, dann mit den Russen.
Aber das sagt die Regierung wieder nicht, oh, wir haben Angst vor den Russen,
weil da müsste man sagen, okay, dann sorgt doch dafür, dass die nicht weiterkommen.
Das wäre doch die logische Konsequenz. Schiebt die Sachen vor.
Die Ukrainer übernehmen ja sozusagen die Toten und genau, also die schicken
ihre Soldaten in den Tod, wenn man ihnen das Equipment gibt.
Das ist ja rein politisch sogar noch der bessere Deal.
Und da sagen die, da verstehen sie nicht, warum das nicht gemacht wird.
Also sie stehen da und sagen, wir erledigen den Job, aber gib uns einfach nur das Werkzeug.
Und ich verstehe das auch nicht. Das ist für mich ein Mysterium und ich meine
es kann ja im Prinzip nur zwei Erklärungen geben.
Entweder es ist nicht genug Zeug da, was man schicken könnte oder es gibt den
politischen Willen nicht.
Ja oder eben, so kann man die russische Armee weiter abnutzen ohne,
also ich meine, wenn die Ukrainer innerhalb von einer Woche die ganze Ukraine
zurückgewonnen hätten und eine Mauer gebaut hätten, dann hätte die russische
Armee sich ja nicht abgenutzt.
Also da minimal dann hätte man halt
schnellen pakt gehabt oder irgendwie so
was und so also das ist ja auch noch so ein aspekt so wird die russische armee
ja auch immer kleiner und russland immer schwächer also ich meine mit auf und
ab aber am ende tut russland ja nicht gut und das ist glaube ich halt auch so
ein ganz perverse spiel was da gespielt wird dass man sagt na ja aber dann so
nur ganz langsam abreiben.
Ich meine, das ist natürlich sehr schwierig, so eine Position einzunehmen,
weil es natürlich eine sehr zynische Position ist und sicherlich gibt es hier
auch keine einheitliche Haltung.
Also jedes Land in der EU hat da schon eine andere Position und müssen ja nicht
weit gucken. Auch in Deutschland haben wir ja sozusagen von akuten Putin-Verstehern
bis Total Hawks eigentlich auch alles am Start.
Es ist immer nur die Frage, wie ist es sozusagen verteilt und wer sieht welchen Aspekt.
Kommt man da jetzt raus aus der Situation? Ich meine, derzeit ist natürlich
alles unhold wegen der amerikanischen Wahl.
Und das ist ja, glaube ich, jedem klar, dass das jetzt erstmal die Bremse ist.
In drei Tagen ist immer eine Rammstein-Konferenz, meine ich, die nächste.
Die ist jetzt verschoben worden wegen des Hurricanes.
Nein, okay, ja gut. Aber das wäre so der nächste Meilenstein ja zumindest gewesen
oder je nachdem, was bei rumkommt, ja dann die US-Wahl.
Und wo, also, was mir scheint bei der US-Wahl erstmal, wer es wird,
halte ich da immer noch für offen, bis die letzte Stimme abgegeben ist.
Also, dass es da Überraschungen gibt, haben wir jetzt oft genug erlebt.
Und dann der andere Punkt auch bei Harris. Ich meine, die,
Sie äußert sich ja zu vielen Sachen nicht ganz klar zur Zeit,
also was ja ein politisches Kalkül ist total.
Nur mir ist da nicht so, also ich gehe von aus, dass sie einen ähnlichen Kurs
weiterfahren würde wie bisher, aber bin ich mir auch nicht sicher.
Ja, so, also das würde ich so herleiten aus dem, was es bisher gab,
dass sie pro-Ukraine ist.
Aber sie hat ja jetzt kein, nicht sozusagen Paper-Ukraine mal rausgerückt,
was sie jetzt, was ist ihr Plan oder so.
Und bei Trump habe ich immer das Gefühl, das kommt drauf an,
ob am Morgen der Kaffee gut oder schlecht war, wie sich das jetzt dreht mit Ukraine.
Und er kann halt in beide Richtungen einen massiven Einfluss drauf haben.
Und das also, ja, also sozusagen nicht, also für mich ist der Punkt,
wenn man jetzt wüsste, in welche Richtung es geht,
dann könnten ja auch die Militärs ein paar Ebenen darunter sagen,
schicken wir jetzt noch alles los, was im Rahmen unserer Möglichkeiten selber
zu entscheiden ist? oder haben wir Zeit?
Mir scheint halt, also es ist ja nicht mal klar, wo wir in einem Monat stehen
mit den Entscheidungen.
Also ob es dann heißt, wir schicken Nukes an die Ukraine und setzt die ein,
wie ihr wollt, weil Trump irgendwie einen lustigen Tag hatte oder ob es heißt,
wir machen jetzt einen Deal mit Putin und was weiß ich was.
Also ich glaube, das ist so, also wenn man immer meint, bei deutschen Wahlen
sei das Ergebnis so offen, denke ich, ach guck mal in die Die USA,
bei uns ist der Bereich doch deutlich schmaler, zumindest bei den Parteien,
die es auf Bundesebene werden können.
Von was wir eine Überraschung haben können, in den USA finde ich es so verworren,
dass man nicht mal, also oder ich könnte nicht mal annähernd einen Tipp abgeben,
wo ich meine, wo wir in einem Monat stehen.
Also was glaube ich auch bei der Wahl derzeit noch ein bisschen aus dem,
zumindest aus dem europäischen Fokus gerät, es kommt ja auch nicht nur auf die
Präsidentschaft allein an, sondern es wird ja sowohl der Kongress,
der sich derzeit in der Hand der Republikaner hält,
also die halt eine Mehrheit haben und damit ja auch schon eine ganze Menge Ärger gemacht haben,
als auch der Senat teilweise neu gewählt.
Es wird ja immer so die Hälfte neu bestimmt und ich habe relativ wenig Prognosen,
was die Wahl zum Repräsentantenhaus betrifft, gelesen tatsächlich. Ich weiß nicht.
Ich wüsste jetzt gerade gar nicht mal, wie da die Einschätzung ist,
aber ich würde mal meinen, mit einem Gewinn von Harris gibt es auch durchaus
eine Chance, dass sie den Teil wieder zurückbekommen. Wo es aber sehr schwierig
zu sein scheint, ist halt die Senatswahl.
Was daran liegt, dass die Demokraten derzeit, also die haben ja genau 100 Sitze,
derzeit ist die Verteilung zwischen Demokraten und Republikanern bei 50-50 und
damit ist die Vizepräsidentin, also Kamala Harris derzeit quasi der Tiebreaker
für jede beliebige Entscheidung,
sodass sie quasi im Senat noch mitbestimmen dürfen.
Also jetzt aus der Perspektive der Präsidentschaft heraus, aber den Kongress gegen sich haben.
Jetzt könnte es nach dieser Wahl genau andersrum sein, weil die Senatsposten,
die neu gewählt werden, da sind halt drei oder vier oder fünf dabei,
die zwar derzeit von Demokraten gehalten werden,
aber die alle so Wackelkandidaten sind, weil es eigentlich so immer Republican-Leaning ist etc.
Und der eine Demokrat hier, dieser Minchin oder wie er heißt,
der schon immer super hardcore konservativ war, der tritt nicht wieder an und
ist halt auch nicht davon auszugehen.
Also in anderen Worten weiß man noch nicht, vielleicht gibt es ein paar Überraschungen
in Texas und so weiter, aber es kann eben sehr gut sein, dass selbst wenn Kamala
Harris Präsidentin wird,
dass das nächste Deadlock dann sozusagen im Senat gibt und das spielt sicherlich
auch eine Rolle in den Meinungsäußerungen, die wir derzeit sehen.
Umso mehr wird natürlich davon der EU abhängen.
Die sich also auch erstmal da wieder neu finden muss.
Jetzt hatten wir leider die letzten
EU-Wahlen, die auch sehr viel rechtsgerichtetere Parteien gestärkt hat.
Interessanterweise hat ausgerechnet die Partei von Orbán wiederum Stimmen verloren
und in Ungarn ist ohnehin gerade
so eine etwas schwierig einzuschätzende Anti-Stimmung gegenüber Orbán.
Da gibt es ja jetzt so einen Contender, der so ein bisschen den Eindruck macht,
als könnte er ihm dann vielleicht mal das Zepter entreißen, aber das hat man
auch schon öfter gedacht, dass das sein wird.
Und wie schon angesprochen, Slowakei, also es gibt so einen Widerstand.
Vielleicht kommt jetzt auch Österreich noch mit dazu.
Was ist so dein Eindruck, wird sich die EU dort fangen können?
Ich befürchte nicht richtig. Also ich meine, es sind ja verschiedene Ebenen.
Zum einen erstmal das Politische, ob man da überhaupt auf einen stabilen Ast kommt.
Ich meine, die EU ist nicht dafür bekannt, dass sie schnell und in eine Richtung entscheidet.
Also wenn es um Fettwert in Joghurt geht, dann das kriegen wir geregelt.
Ich meine, das Klischee kommt ja leider irgendwo her, dass das immer nicht so klappt.
Ich meine dann, wenn man jetzt wirklich sagen würde, also ich meine,
abgesehen von EU, wir könnten ja auch in Deutschland anders agieren,
also es hat ja so viele Ebenen.
Also ich denke, selbst wenn sich jetzt die EU entscheiden würde,
das zu übernehmen, was die Amis machen, das denke ich auch immer ist ein bisschen blöd.
Die Amis werden dafür kritisiert, dass sie sich überall einmischen,
aber Waffen sollen sie bitte trotzdem liefern in einen Konflikt,
der uns mehr angeht. Er sagt, ja entscheidet euch für eins, dann sagt auch Amis,
haltet euch raus und wir übernehmen jetzt alles, was ihr macht.
Dann hätten wir eine starke EU, also militärisch und politisch.
So und dann müssten die Waffen irgendwo herkommen.
Das wären ja, also ich meine, es gibt zumindest die hochwertigen Waffen,
mal ganz vereinfacht gesagt, wäre dann halt Frankreich und Deutschland wieder
die, die es machen müssten oder signifikant machen müssten.
Und dann sehen wir ja die Sachen, wie es hier jetzt 100 Milliarden Sondervermögen
gibt und Panzerfabriken, die nicht hochgefahren werden und diese ganzen tausend
Probleme, die wir haben, die ja nicht mal mit der EU zu tun haben,
sondern nur mit unserer eigenen Politik bisher.
Ja, wo ich dann auch denke, naja, nee,
also ich sehe nicht, wie das, also wenn wir jetzt selber in Deutschland die
ganze Zeit voll durchziehen würden, dann könnte man sagen, gut,
dann könnte man das vielleicht auch auf einer EU-Ebene sozusagen hochbringen
oder sagen, guck mal, wir gehen hier mit gutem Beispiel voran.
Aber in jedem Land ist es irgendwie so ein Chaos. Und dann setzen sich die zusammen,
die in ihrem Land nicht richtig an einem Strang ziehen.
Und dann soll was Gutes bei rauskommen. Und wo ich denke, naja, ich glaube nicht.
Weil, also wir können jetzt einiges an Waffen liefern, was wir so haben. Das ist ganz gut.
Aber es ist ja jetzt nicht so, als hätten wir mal richtig Produktion hochgefahren.
Oder überhaupt nur was in die Richtung mal gestartet.
Und das ist so, das verstehe ich nicht. Also ganz grundlegend müsste die EU
jetzt ja mal hü oder hot sagen.
Und ich glaube, das zerfaselt sich wieder so.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das in absehbarer Zeit eine klare Linie gibt.
Tja.
Der Vorhang zu und alle Fragen offen.
Ja, ich denke dabei können wir es jetzt vielleicht auch erstmal belassen.
Die Fragen sind offen und klar.
Sehr viel wird jetzt einfach in der ganzen internationalen Debatte von der Wahl abhängen.
Positiv kann man sagen, in beiden Fällen muss sich die EU neu positionieren.
Also sowohl, wenn Trump kommt, dann wird es nochmal so einen Ruck geben,
der sehr wohl meiner Meinung nach dazu führen kann, dass dieses Eigenständigkeitsding,
also alle gucken jetzt sozusagen, müssen wir? Ja genau.
Und Trump, ja, heißt halt, ja, wir müssen.
Oder kommt Kamala Harris, dann wird man natürlich noch mal abwarten,
okay, was ist jetzt die Policy?
Ich bin, was sie betrifft, relativ optimistisch, was ihr Verhältnis zu Ukraine betrifft.
Gar nicht mal so sehr, weil ich ihr das zutraue, das tue ich auch,
dass sie das sozusagen alles richtig einschätzen kann, sondern allein schon,
weil ihr Vize so ein starker Ukrainer-Supporter ist.
Tim Walz war ja schon immer da ganz klar positioniert und wenn er auch nur irgendwie
ein bisschen Einfluss hat auf sie, dann dürfte das sicherlich in dem Fall zum Tragen kommen.
Da kann ich mir also schon durchaus vorstellen, dass da was ist und da sie nun
auch eine andere Generation,
vertritt und wir mit beiden sozusagen den Abgang eines kalten Kriegers haben
und das jetzt sozusagen durch jemand ersetzt wird, der vielleicht sehr viel
mehr von dem Niedergang der Sowjetunion und der Zeit danach,
politisch geprägt worden ist,
kann da schon durchaus was passieren.
Was Deutschland betrifft, habe ich relativ wenig Hoffnung, muss ich zugeben.
Merz oder Scholz, buchen Sie sich auf.
Genau, du weißt ja auch, was aus Scholz und Merz zusammen wird.
Scherz.
Schmerz. Schmerz, ja. Genau das.
Ja, gut. Okay, Enno, ich sage vielen Dank für die Ausführung,
war sehr interessant und ich wäre gerne mitgekommen, aber es war ein bisschen zu kurzfristig.
Nächste Runde.
Nächste Runde, genau. Insofern vielen Dank an alle fürs Zuhören.
Das war es von UKW und wir werden demnächst mal die Scherben zusammenkehren,
glaube ich, wenn die US-Wahl ansteht oder dann vorbei ist und anstehen tut sie ja jetzt.
Und dann schauen wir mal, wie es weitergeht in diesem Konflikt.
Okay, das war Spaß. Ich sage tschüss und bis bald.